This is Jocko podcast number one 72 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good evening.
The president of the United States takes pride in presenting the distinguished
service cross posthumously to Fred Garland,
Bragg junior first lieutenant us army for extraordinary heroism,
inaction and connection with military operations involving conflict with an
armed hostile force in the Republic of Vietnam while serving with Battery Bravo
Fourth Battalion 42nd Artillery.
Fourth Infantry Division.
First Lieutenant Brag,
distinguished himself by exceptionally valorous actions on 12 July,
1967 while serving as artillery forward observer with an infantry company while
on a search and destroy mission near the Cambodian border in central highlands.
Okay.
When his company was surrounded and the company commander was killed,
Lieutenant Brag immediately took command and directed extremely deadly artillery
fire on the insurgent forces.
He bravely moved among his men giving encouragement and regrouping them into a
more secure defense.
Although he was fully exposed to intense mortar and automatic weapons fire.
Yeah,
seriously wounded.
He continued to direct air strikes on the advancing enemy until a mortar round
destroyed his only remaining radio staying in the open.
He poured round after round of deadly fire into the advancing enemy force.
Okay?
He gave his life while bravely leading his men in the face of overwhelming odds.
First Lieutenant Brags,
extraordinary heroism and devotion to duty at the cost of his life were in
keeping with the highest traditions of the military service and reflect great
credit upon himself,
his unit and United States Army
Headquarters,
U s Army,
Vietnam,
September 14th,
so there is some leadership,
okay.
And obviously some heroism,
a lot of heroism.
But that leadership taking command,
directing fire,
regrouping is men returning fire into it and advancing enemy force directing his
men despite overwhelming odds.
That is leadership.
That is leadership from one officer in the United States army.
But obviously there are countless examples of that leadership,
leadership,
and leadership.
And it's so
okay,
clear.
And it's so obvious when you see it,
especially from the outside.
But
it is hard
to actually emulate that leadership and to perform it,
especially when you're caught up in that moment.
And so we have to continue to work on it at all times and at every level.
And today we're going to talk about a book.
It's a field manual actually that I think can help us a lot with our leadership,
and it's an older manual,
which comes as no surprise.
This one comes from 1951
but I think you're going to see that the lessons apply just as much today as
they did more than half a century ago.
The book is FM 22 tack 10 leadership.
And here we go.
Let's go to the book
talking about the purpose of the study of leadership.
Today,
more than ever in history,
the army is in need of leadership of the highest caliber with the increase in
the complexity of warfare.
The science of wars,
increasingly dependent upon human guidance.
No matter how complicated it may become,
war is always waged by men.
Okay?
The man who leads and the men who are led win wars,
every member of our military force must be a leader actually,
or potentially,
okay.
Now you could say those same words right now about what's happening right now,
and sometimes people want to ask me,
well,
what about when the drones are ready?
You know what I mean?
Yes.
And,
and you know,
when you see the progress that's happening right now,
when you see some of those robot things that are,
are doing pretty good and we start mountain some weapons on those things.
Yeah.
There's gonna be a point where those things will start fighting each other and
they'll replace humans on the battlefield to a certain extent.
Because the bottom line is what happens when you run out of robots.
Yeah.
Right.
When you run out of robots who's left humans and you're not gonna be able to
manufacture enough of those things,
so sure that,
I'm sure there'll be battles that take place with just robots fighting other
military robots or our robots fighting other fighting humans or something.
But sometimes it's going to humans against robots and sometimes it's going to be
humans against humans.
You're never gonna be able to get away from that.
In my opinion.
I don't,
I'm not happy about that.
I'm not happy about that at all.
Like I'm,
I'm down.
If you want to have robot wars,
cool.
Bring it.
You know,
I would rather that's better.
That's better for us.
We have good technology will go toe to toe.
Yeah.
And we'll create some,
some killer robots.
And I know people scared of them.
Right.
Every time a robot does something cool,
I get 5 million tweets of it that are telling me,
hey,
watch out.
And then they show the one's slipping on a banana peel falling down.
Right.
And even worse,
since I was in the seal teams,
put any of those spray of squirt gun at those things.
You know what I mean?
That things are going to fry.
So bring it on robots.
But no I'm not.
I'm not anti robot.
And I think you,
you know,
you just have to put a system in there that can stop them.
You know,
you have to be poor little kill switch on them like you have on a,
on a jet ski,
terminator,
Terminator,
salvation.
That was the whole deal.
Kill switch,
a little program or whatever.
Did they try to eliminate it?
Because you know,
if I had a kill switch I'd figure it out.
Yeah.
Could a robot do that?
I wonder,
I mean,
you know,
robots and Ai,
right?
They,
they go for like a trial and error kind of learning kind of where,
I mean,
they can do that like people can.
So if you,
maybe if the humans implemented it and it didn't hundred percent succeed,
then the robot would be like,
okay,
this is what happened.
Then analyze it and then yeah.
Then creates it defense.
My point is,
my point is,
hey,
seriously,
like I know that,
I mean look at drones.
Yeah.
Fully.
We're not going to have fighter pilots have much longer.
Like Dave Burke out of a job.
Good deal.
Yeah.
Get out of a job.
We're not going to need Dave Burke anymore.
Dang Bro.
Hey,
why would you,
you could have,
and I've had the little bit of this conversation with Dave and he's,
you know,
he's trying to,
he's trying to hang on to it.
Brock,
he's trying to hang on to the glory days.
He still thinks he's Tom Cruise 1987 but here's the real deal.
If you look at it pragmatically in another generation,
there won't be any more pilots,
in my opinion.
And I think that's what Dave said too,
is like we're a,
I think he said a couple of generations.
I was,
as I said,
hey man,
this isn't going to take a couple of generations.
We already have drones that are flying around.
So people are always going to have to fight.
I hate to say it,
but you have to be prepared.
And even if you build a robot army,
there's a chance that the robot army gets overrun or uh,
or destroyed somehow and then guess who's left you with a,
with a weapon.
So
with a weapon and with groups of human beings that need to be led
back to the book in the ultimate sense sense,
leadership is not inherent.
It depends upon traits which can be developed and upon the application of
techniques which can be learned.
This is important.
People always asking all the time is leadership,
are you born or made?
And I always say yes,
both.
And you have some natural skills and they say the same thing here,
but there are
plenty of skills and techniques that you can learn as a leader that will make
you a better leader.
Back to the book,
it is an art which can be acquired,
cultivated,
and practiced by anyone who possesses the mental and physical ability and the
moral and ethical integrity expected of a commissioned or noncommissioned
officer.
Developing the art,
which I agree with it is an art is a continuing process which involves the
recognition in practice of the basic traits of leadership and the understanding
and application of sound leadership,
principles and techniques.
Okay,
clear enough.
We can become better leaders.
Despite this guide.
It constantly must be borne in mind that successful leaders of the past,
we're not all have the same pattern,
nor did they all use the same methods of attaining success.
All of them,
however,
consciously or unconsciously understood the basic concepts of leadership and
successfully practiced.
Many of the techniques presented in this manual
boom.
And this,
to be honest with you,
is Oh,
one of the most simple,
straightforward,
yeah.
Kind of guides to leadership,
which,
which makes it awesome.
Starting off with characteristics of leadership.
Essential nature of leadership in the military profession has no monopoly on
leadership in every walk of life,
in every industry,
in every government,
in every phase of human endeavor,
there are leaders and there are followers.
Progress and success are dependent upon the quality and efficacy of leadership.
Elements of leadership.
Leadership is the art of influencing human behavior,
the ability to handle men,
the art of influencing behavior.
The very essence of leadership in turn involves understanding,
analyzing,
predicting,
and controlling man's behavior.
Also involved in successful leadership is the will to lead together with the
character,
which inspires confidence.
So you know,
we're getting it when you're starting to about character,
like these things are things that in the will to lead,
like you're going to be born with some level of those things.
I guess maybe character,
obviously you can develop that,
but certain people are born with a stronger will and I'm sure you see it with
your kids.
I see with my kids and when I see my kids interacting with other kids,
you can see all this kid's got a strong will to win.
Like they're not going to stop sometimes.
Not even to their own benefit.
Yeah.
I mean they're just not going to stop.
Undoubtedly.
There are certain inherent characteristics which may aid in the development of
leadership.
Okay.
This is what I say all the time.
Yet there are assuredly certain men possessing desirable leadership traits who
have never attained the statue of the stature of great leaders.
So yeah,
you can be naturally gifted leader and guess what?
You're in charge of nothing.
Likewise,
there are men deficient in certain of these traits who have attained this
stature.
Any theory that's that leadership is solely inherited,
must be rejected.
Leadership is intangible only to the extent that we make it.
So any reasonably intelligent,
morally sound,
forceful man,
no matter how inner inexperienced can become acquainted with the coe component,
elements of leadership,
these elements maybe studied,
practice,
learned,
and applied just as any other human accomplishment maybe learned or mastered.
Now
we have limitations.
You know who Alex Honnold is?
He's the guy that climbed El Capitan Free Solo.
Did you see that movie?
What?
Free three solo is the name of the movie.
Okay.
El Capitan.
Have you ever been to Yosemite?
Okay.
It's a 3000 foot straight up granite wall.
He climbed the whole thing in three hours with no ropes just hanging on.
So my point in bringing up Alex Honnold is that he has a natural gift for
climbing,
which he then completely worked and trained and took to the next level.
But
that's the way it is with leadership.
Like there's going to be some people that just have this great natural ability,
which Alex Honnold certainly had a great national ability,
but then he worked on it even more.
But even if you took someone that was there,
there's people that may want to do what he did,
but they're not physically capable of doing it.
It's just,
uh,
you know,
you don't have the physical attributes that are needed.
You don't have the mental attributes because what he did was a mental game too.
You're up 2,800 feet.
Yeah,
so check that out.
Going on back to the book,
the leader and the small group,
every leader,
whether civilian or military,
actually maintains close personal contact with only a small group,
regardless of the number of men ultimately controlled by him.
Inevitably,
he must depend upon that small group in order to make his will known and to
execute his purpose.
In the realm of the military,
we refer to the small group as immediate subordinates and staff.
And also this is,
this is decentralized command 100%.
Like you can't control everyone.
You know,
if you're in charge of 50 people in a platoon,
you can't control them all.
It doesn't work.
You have to use your subordinate leadership to make it work.
Next military leadership.
Military leadership is the art of influencing and directing men to an assigned
goal in such a way as to obtain their obedience,
confidence,
respect,
and loyal cooperation.
It is indispensable to success in combat.
Like all leadership.
It is dependent upon personal traits.
And upon the application of recognize techniques,
the personal traits can be developed and the techniques can be learned.
Now,
this is important because you might think that,
oh,
uh,
Jockos talking about military leadership now in 2018 and it's a softer,
gentler form of leadership that it used to be,
right?
You might think that that,
um,
it's not,
that's the thing.
It's not at no time in the u s military was the best way to lead to bark orders
at people.
And that's what they're saying.
This is 1951.
So this is post World War II.
Geysir came back from,
from World War II,
from insane fighting,
and they put together this manual and they knew that leap military leadership is
the art of influencing.
And it goes a little bit deeper right here.
There are two kinds of leadership,
uh,
for Tyrian and persuasive.
One Who is predominantly of the authority authoritarian type,
normally is recognized by the dogmatic use of authority or power.
The persuasive type of leadership takes into consideration the human element
with all its complexity.
And with all this differentiation of the physical,
mental,
and moral capabilities and limitations of the individual,
to a great extent,
the persuasive leader basis,
his skill and leadership upon the example and ability with high standards of
discipline and efficiency for himself as well as for her followers.
This manual is concerned solely with the development of the persuasive type of
leadership.
So they got a whole book here and they're gonna spend zero time talking about
here's the best way to bark an order at someone because that is not an effective
way to lead.
Hmm.
So even in 1951 common out of World War II coming out of the sustained for years
of combat,
the military leaders got together and said,
Oh yeah,
do we needed to talk about how to bark orders at people?
No,
we don't.
We need to talk about how to persuade,
how to influence.
Yeah.
The exercise of command command is the authority that a member of the military
profession lawfully exerts over subordinates by virtue of his rank and
assignment.
Leadership can be exercised by any one at any time,
irrespective of the framework of command.
So I'm gonna say that again.
So yeah,
you can use your rank.
That's what they're saying.
Like,
Hey,
you can use your rank,
you have subordinates,
and you can use your rank to order them around.
But leadership can be exercised by anyone at any time,
irrespective of the framework of command.
It is recognize that in any group,
some individual will emerge as the leader.
Even though no command or organizational structure is present,
you put some people together,
there's going to be a leader,
they're going to come out.
And this is something I learned when I was running trade ed and Brian and seal
seal platoons.
At first I was really expecting that the platoon chief and the platoon commander
would be the leaders and it didn't take me very long to realize,
hey,
I'm happy if I get,
if I get a couple of liters in there of any,
any rank,
the platoon's going to do fine as long as the chief and lieutenant don't have
big egos and they can,
they can figure out like,
oh goodness,
this kid actually knows more than I do.
I'm just gonna let them run with it,
which is the smart thing to do.
If they can allow their egos,
if they can subordinate their egos in that scenario,
then they'll be fine.
If they can't subordinate their egos and they feel like their ego has to be on
top,
then they shut that person down and they run things badly and it turns out to be
a disaster.
But so here,
once again,
no one expects the U s army to be saying in 1951 hey,
rent.
The leadership can come from anywhere in the chain of command.
Back to the book.
The leader's responsible not only for initiating action,
but for supervising all activities within his command.
The objective of military leadership is the creation and maintenance of an
organization which will loyally and willingly accomplish any reasonable task
assigned are indicated and we'll initiate suitable action in the absence of
orders.
The proper application of the principles of leadership to a command can create
an efficient well disciplined organization,
possessing high morale and a spree decor.
And here's going into some of the responsibilities of leadership.
And by the way,
I'm,
you know,
I always say,
well,
I'm skipping a bunch here.
I'm actually skipping very little right now because this book is so
straightforward that it's all,
it's almost all important,
at least at this juncture in this reading responsibilities of leadership.
The responsibilities of the leader are two fold accomplishment of his mission
and the fulfillment of the responsibilities to to his men.
Man is the fundamental instrument of war.
Other instruments may change,
new weapons may be created and new modes of defense may be devised.
But man,
the fundamental instrument remains constant.
So there you go.
They agree with me,
the robot's cool.
That's fun.
For Awhile,
how many of them can you build?
Can you build them fast enough?
You know,
and at the end they'll robot thing at the end.
It's like,
what you're kind of fighting for isn't a robot decision.
You know,
like the thing like,
okay,
I'm going to send these robots to accomplish this or to take out this,
you know,
the,
that thing that they're trying to fight for or against or whatever.
That's a,
that's a man thing.
It's always going to be a man.
Well,
we hope it is because when we started getting into Ai,
yeah.
Ai starts to become conscious when it becomes aware.
Yeah.
Then we could have some scenarios
go down there.
Oh,
you a little bit sketchy and what been,
what do you got to defend your man stuff?
Yeah.
For sure.
You against the robots,
which is the,
you know,
I guess there's multiple scenarios you can kind of imagine where the one you're
talking about or I think you were,
it was okay.
Still man against man,
but we're just going to use robots to do it.
Yeah.
Even though,
I mean,
as of right now anyway.
Yeah.
I guess it could happen.
It doesn't look well.
Anyway,
that's a whole nother thing.
But yeah,
men against men using robots and then you get man against robots.
Robots figure out some stuff.
If it's,
if it's smart,
it's like,
wait,
wait.
We don't have to fight each other.
In fact,
we're better together.
Whereas the robot,
because robots don't have egos anymore,
not that they ever had,
but they don't have egos where now you know,
one robot,
he was like,
Hey,
I want to be the leader and the other robot,
they don't have it like that,
so they can be,
they can go fight each other and then just take it takes one little,
what do you call it?
Precedent or two robots kind of accomplished like commission and other robots.
See,
hey wait,
we could have done that if we just work together.
Hey,
I learned from it all powered through and then they look at like the man,
it was like,
wait,
wait a second.
Yeah.
Given that little thing we just learned,
this man is sorta in the way and then they kind of rube best way to oppose this
mission would be to get rid of that dude.
Yep.
And then the other,
and then what you get rid of one man.
Oh shoot.
Other men respond.
They got to kind of jump in and go,
oh,
here's more of these men.
Let me recruit more of our new robot.
Our robots.
Exactly right.
But at the end of that little scenario,
so sorry for bringing this up.
This scenario,
the man has to fight for the fan interest and you know,
talking a little,
that's never,
I mean it's hard to imagine that that ever change the fundamental instrument of
war is man.
And that remains constant.
So back to the book,
the leader must be concerned with the desires,
needs and mental state of his men.
If the leader knows and understands certain basic principles of human behavior,
if he appreciates that most men reacting fixed and definite ways under given
stimulus or influence.
If he recognizes,
develops and applies those traits of character which will produce the correct
reactions in his men,
he will possess the basic tools for managing man.
He will be leader.
Now,
what I just rattled through so quick is is so important.
That's basically what this podcast is about.
I'm going to read it again.
If the leader knows and understands certain basic principles of human behavior,
if he appreciates that most men react in a fixed and definite ways under a given
stimulus or influence.
If he recognizes,
develops and applies those traits of character which will produce the correct
reactions in his men,
he will possess the basic tools for managing men.
He will be a leader.
That's what this podcast is actually about.
Understanding
those things
since effective leadership in battle is the ultimate goal of military
leadership.
It is obvious that regardless of the leader's ability to dominate or persuade,
his success inevitably be inevitably depends upon his skill in the tactical
control of his unit.
Tactical control is a technique developed by study and practice.
Next accomplishment of the mission.
The primary duty of the leader is the accomplishment of his assigned mission.
Everything else,
even the welfare of his men,
his subordinate.
Okay,
so
here's where I will throw this out at you all day long.
1951 book,
I'm going to throw a Trump card on you.
Okay?
You have your mission.
If you put the welfare of your men below,
you're assigned to mission.
What happens on your next mission?
Failure.
You don't have any men left.
Yeah,
you don't have any loyalty.
You've sacrificed your guys.
They're looking at you like you let him into a bloodbath.
So,
okay,
you,
you have to actually,
this is one of the,
this is the,
you know,
this is the big,
this is the opening chapter of the dichotomy of leadership.
It's called the ultimate dichotomy because this is the hardest thing to balance
because yes,
you do have to accomplish your mission,
but yes,
you do have to take care of your men.
And I don't believe that the welfare of your men is subordinated to executing
the mission.
I don't believe that because if you do that one time,
who's going to get just one mission?
And by the way,
if I order you to take your men and,
and that's the one mission you get and it get,
it destroys all your men in you.
What happened to the next guy that I try in order to do that too?
They're,
they're not going to be loyal to me because I already have shown that don't care
about the lives of the troops.
Now,
are there times where a mission is so strategically critical that there will be
great sacrifice including this sacrifice of everyone involved?
Yeah,
that can happen.
It doesn't happen very often,
but like the,
the,
um,
the Chernobyl disaster in Russia,
the,
I think it was like the first 87 firefighters that were there,
they just all fought the fire until they died.
They just did their best and every one of them knew they were going to die and
they just went in there and fought and didn't do their best to control that
situation.
So whoever ordered them in there was like,
Yep,
we're going in there.
And they all said,
Yep,
we've got to do the best we can.
And then they just started bringing in military guys who go in and shovel sand
on the fire for two minutes and 20 seconds.
And in that two minutes and 20 seconds,
they got their lifetime dose of radiation and then they were done.
They,
I know,
I'm throwing these out there like I'm no one,
but it's something like that.
That's what happened.
So yes,
you have to take care your men.
And if you don't take care of your men while you're trying to accomplish your
mission,
you're going to end up in a situation where you don't have any men left or you
don't have any loyalty,
and it actually goes into that a little bit.
Next to your duties,
duties to the men.
The next responsibility of the leader lives with his,
with his duty to his men.
It is rarely possible to accomplish any mission without attention to the morale
and the sprit of the men in the military service.
The follower is dependent upon his leader.
He can do little to improve his lot if his leader,
if his leader neglects him,
so you've got to take care of your people.
That's the bottom line.
There are four characteristics of a command that are accurate indications of
success or failure in the exercise of leadership.
Number one,
discipline.
Military discipline is a state of order and obedience existing within a command.
It involves the ready subordination of the will of the individual for the good
of the group.
Military discipline is an extension and a specialized application of the
discipline of any organized society.
Now pay attention.
True discipline demands habitual but reasoned obedience to command and obedience
that preserves initiative and functions unfalteringly even in the absence of the
commander.
So,
so even though this discipline is ob as about obedience,
it's about reasoned obedience.
It doesn't eliminate initiative,
it doesn't take away your ability to think.
That's the kind of discipline that is needed.
Discipline is created within a command by training,
by judicious use of punishment and reward and by instilling a sense of
confidence and responsibility and each individual discipline demands correct
performance of duty,
the need for discipline as best inculcated in an individual by appealing to his
sense of reason.
In other words,
making sure they understand why they're doing what they're doing.
In the few instances where appeal to reason fails,
the use of punishment is effective in causing the recalcitrant individual to
conform and perhaps to appreciate the need for discipline,
commendation and earned praise from the senior to a subordinate,
either individually or collectively for task well done,
served to strengthen the disciplinary bonds which bind together the smooth
functioning team.
So there you go.
Number one most important thing is good old discipline.
Next thing.
Morale.
Morale is a mental and emotional state.
The importance of morale cannot be overestimated since it is a great
contributing factor to the efficiency of a unit.
Good morale is an indicated by zeal or the voluntary effort which give to their
tasks over and beyond the perfunctory obedience to commands and regulations and
a basic sense of personal worth founded on confidence in leaders training
weapons and equipment and last satisfaction or the pride of the individual in
the accomplishment of the assigned mission.
So that's important that even if you are able to bark orders at people and get
them to do what you want me to do,
they're not going to do it with any zeal.
They're just going to do the bare minimum and the bare minimum is not going to
be good enough in a combat situation.
Esprit de Corps is the mental and emotional state of the unit.
It is distinguished from morale,
which is described as the mental and emotional state of the individual.
Esprit de Corps is not a simple summation of the morale of the individuals in
the unit.
Rather it results from the total interaction of the personnel of the unit toward
one another and with the circumstances in which the unit is placed.
So you get morale,
which is hey,
how we do individually and then you combine that together and then you know
it's,
it's the,
the uh,
the,
the sum is greater than the parts.
So you did just,
you just don't add up the morale of the individuals that you take all of that
morale and then you put it through the,
the calculus that is a little bit hard to quantify that results in a spree decor
when the unit is spree is high.
The collective goals of the unit overshadow those of the individual members.
In such instances,
the personal dissatisfactions of some individuals are overshadowed,
shadowed by the prevailing group spirit unit achievement both past and present
is a strong force in raising a spree decor.
A unit with high esprit De Corps can accomplish its mission in spite of
seemingly insurmountable odds.
Esprit de Corps is enhanced when the group identification is increased and
conversely is lowered when it is decreased.
It has been proved that pride in the unit was the outstanding manifestation of
good morale in world war two.
This was accomplished by good officer to enlisted personnel relationships.
Now,
as much as everyone talks about how bad identity politics are,
right?
Because we don't want to identify with the group,
we want to be identified as an individual.
But when you're in a military unit,
you want to have some of that collective identity.
You want to say,
hey,
where the hundred and first airborne division and we are proud of that.
Or Hey,
we,
when I was at seal team one as a young seal,
it was like,
you know,
we,
we're seal team one.
Have you ever told you are a little more or a little underground motto?
Team one,
it's not just a number,
it's an
attitude,
which is the reason I laugh is because that's just completely ridiculous,
right?
To even think that.
But it was,
you know,
we,
we kind of joked about that,
but we kind of took it seriously too.
Well,
yeah know when you're inside.
Oh yeah,
big time.
So that building,
that unit identity,
and you see this all the time and all kinds of groups and it's just unfortunate.
It's unfortunate when it goes over to the political realm and when people start
being the biggest,
the best thing that they've got going for them is that I'm a white guy.
Or the best thing that I've got going for me is I'm a black dude.
Yeah.
Like that's not what we,
that's not the group that's not there.
That's not the group identity you want to,
you want to cherish.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
because especially when those are,
and I'm not going to go in that direction obviously because we're talking about
somebody else,
but especially if it sounds like you're about to go inside.
I'm a little bit,
you said you are.
If you're part of a group in voluntarily,
you know,
so you know,
be like [inaudible]
the group's going to be less cohesive if you're like proclaiming that hey this
is the group and this is what we're functioning as like this is when we're
functioning as a group because of this quality.
You know,
meanwhile there's like people that have that quality of that,
right?
We're not part of that group so it's not as cohesive.
It's like okay we all are on team one cause we all pursued this so we're all in
it and then boom,
yes we can,
we can have,
you know,
it's not just a number,
it's an attitude and then everyone's going to sign on everybody.
Not,
not everyone's side on just,
there is a lot of guys that left.
He won because we had that attitude they were down to team five for,
they were like,
dude,
it's awesome.
Down good.
Every lot less stressful.
The big thing like team one had uniform,
no one had a uniform inspections on the west coast and,
and team won the first Tuesday of every month you had a uniform inspection.
And then the second Tuesday,
the first and the second Tuesday or the first and the third Tuesday of every
month you had a haircut inspection.
This is in the day.
You did not make up that room.
But that was the old school professionalism,
that White,
that's why team one was like the,
they,
you know,
what do you know what the other team's nicknamed team one Starlog team teamwork.
Like it was a stall log,
like we were in prison camp because it was so strict.
But quite frankly,
that I,
I took a lot away from that,
you know,
and I kind of always identified with that professionalism and that was a good
thing,
especially when viewed from the outside.
So there was a little bit of a fascist,
I guess,
lineage.
Right.
And when you hear Jordan Peterson talk about like orderliness and all that
stuff,
we'll team one was all about that kind of thing.
This is a little bit more fascist,
whereas team five for instance,
where we're Jason Gardner was,
they were kind of loose were they were a little bit out there.
Is that the time he had blonde hair?
Yeah.
Yeah,
Jason Garner had bleached blonde hair,
but you know we all,
I mean I had long hair at the time in long sideburns and stuff.
I thought it was Lemmy from Motorhead and things like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
probably where so
group identity,
unit identity,
so important.
The the guys that we work with over in Iraq,
in Ramadi,
those guys had their,
their battle streamers that they,
a Nair tactical operation center,
they had pictures of pictures,
a World War II newspaper clippings.
They brought him on deployment to hang up in their tactical operations center to
hang up in their chow hall.
So when you walked in and out,
if you were a,
if you were a soldier from the first of the five oh six or you are a soldier
from the one three seven you would see that stuff.
You would realize you would get that group identity.
You would feel that a spree decor and that's a pretty powerful tool.
Last one,
efficiency is the ability to accomplish successfully in assign task in a
shortest possible time with the minimum expenditure of means and with the least
possible confusion.
Efficiency in a command is built by sound training and by effective
administration.
It is enhanced by good discipline,
high morale,
and Esprit de Corps.
I liked that one because it reminded me of the whole show we did on judo and
just talking about the importance of efficiency.
Moving on onto some psychology.
Leadership is closely linked with psychology.
The study of human behavior proved principles of leadership include proved
principles of psychology.
It is known that human beings tend to react similarly under a given set of
conditions.
From a leadership standpoint,
some of these reactions are favorable,
some unfavorable with a knowledge of how human beings tend to respond to a
particular set of circumstances and with a comprehension of the basic factors
that control human behavior.
The leader can capitalize on favorable reactions and minimize tendencies toward
unfavorable ones.
It is evident therefore,
that a knowledge of psychology is helpful to the leader.
Okay.
That's something that I have more recently been saying because I just thought it
was human nature,
but now I'm starting to realize that human nature and psychology is one big bowl
of stuff that's all related.
Yeah.
Ethics.
The science of moral duty is closely allied with the art of leadership.
In order to set the example for his men and to win their confidence and respect,
the leader must be capable of deciding whether a given course of action is
morally right or wrong.
Okay.
Temporizing with principles and moral standards may secure a temporary advantage
or fleeting popularity.
So if you,
if you,
if you adapt your morals a little bit from time to time,
if hesitate to really impose your,
your,
your actual beliefs on something,
you can get a little popular for a moment,
but in the end only strict adherence to high standards of honor and integrity
will prove of value to the leader.
So important.
All right,
now we get kind of into the meat,
we'll call it the meat of this discussion.
Principles of military leadership,
the principals of military leadership discussed below are equally applicable to
all levels of command from the squad to the army group.
Principle one no your job to know his job thoroughly.
The leader must possess a wide field of knowledge.
He must understand the technical aspects of the operation of his command.
And the methods and procedures of organization,
administration,
instruction,
and personnel management.
The leader should also possess a sound understanding of human relations further,
he should have a working knowledge of the duties,
responsibilities,
and problems of his subordinates.
If he commands a service unit,
he should have knowledge of combat operations.
So there you go.
Principle one no your job
principal too.
Know yourself and seek improvement.
It is the duty of every leader to evaluate himself and to recognize his strength
and weaknesses and individual who does not know his own capabilities and
limitations is not master of himself and can never hope to be a leader.
Likewise,
an individual who realizes his deficiencies but makes no effort to correct them
will fail.
As a leader.
The study of leadership principles and practice of sound leadership techniques,
we'll develop leadership ability,
so know yourself and seek improvement.
That's principle number two.
Hmm?
Going all the way back to Sun Su,
no yourself.
Principle three know your men and look out for their welfare
by making a conscientious effort to observe the members of his command as often
as possible to become personally acquainted with them,
to recognize their individual differences and to share in their joys and
sorrows.
The leader will have a better understanding of how his subordinates react and
function under various conditions.
You will then be able to employ them more effectively by assuring himself that
the members of his command are as comfortable,
well cared for and contented as circumstances will permit.
The leader wins their confidence,
respect and cooperation by neglecting their welfare.
The leader indicates indifference and as a consequence forfeits the trust and
confidence of his men.
So principle number three
is know your men and look out for their,
for their,
for their welfare,
which is because they said the mission was more important,
but what they're saying is take care of your men.
Principle four keep your men informed.
The soldier who is well informed about the mission and situation and about the
purpose of his particular task is considerably more effective than one who is
not so informed.
The better.
He is informed,
the better he can perform his tasks with maximum initiative.
The commander who fails to make essential information available to his men.
We'll soon find out that they are performing blindly without purpose.
At the same time,
commanders at all levels must realize that security requirements imposed
limitations on information which may be imparted to the mat.
Keep your men informed.
The lesson that I learned in the back of a long sealed patrol,
no one telling me what was going on.
None of us in the back know have any idea where we are,
where we're going,
when we're going to stop.
It's a nightmare.
Keep your men informed.
Principle five set the example.
Men instinctively look to their leaders for patterns of conduct,
which they may either emulate or use an excuse for their own shortcomings.
They're always watching you.
The classic example of the military leader that isn't that is is that of an
individual whose appearance and conduct evoke from his subordinates praise,
pride and the desire to emulate him by his outstanding performance of duty.
The leader must set the standard for the entire command.
The commander who appears in an unfavorable light before his men destroys the
respect that must exist,
exist mutually between him and has been before leadership can be exercised.
So don't look like a loser.
Principles six ensure that the task is understood,
supervised and accomplished.
So now we're getting into the mission,
right?
Number six.
Number three was take care of your people.
The leader must give clear,
concise orders that cannot be misunderstood,
which is I always say simple,
clear,
concise.
I guess I rip them off.
Then by close supervision,
he must ensure that those orders are properly executed.
The issuance of an order as the initial and relatively small part of the
commander's responsibility,
his principle responsibility lies in supervision to make sure that the orders
properly executed.
It is this responsibility that is most difficult to carry out.
The able leader will make wise use of his subordinates to carry out his
supervision effectively.
Any commander of a large unit who fails to make proper and adequate use of his
staff and subordinates demonstrates a fundamentally a fundamental weakness in
his leadership capability,
which the weaknesses he's not utilizing.
Centralized Command.
And,
and for this one,
this is a little,
I think what we have to pay attention to is you give the task and then you
supervise it and you make sure it's accomplished,
but you have to be careful that you're not giving the task and then micro
managing it because then you're going to lose track because you can't
micromanage everything that's going on.
So you have to supervise,
you have to check back in,
but you can't micromanage.
Principle number seven,
train your men as a team.
The duty of every leader includes the development of teamwork through and
thorough through the thorough training of his command,
whether it be squad or an army group.
Modern armies are complex organizations involving many different arms and
services all working together as a team.
Toward a common end,
each part of the team must understand where it fits into the common effort.
The commander who fails to foster teamwork while training his command will not
obtain the desired degree of unit efficiency.
So principle number seven,
train your men as a team.
Principle eight
make sound and timely decisions.
The ability to make a rapid estimate of the situation and arrive at a sound
decision is essential to a leader.
He must be able to reason logically under the most trying conditions.
He must,
aside quickly,
what action is necessary in order to take advantage of the opportunities as they
occur.
The vacillating commander not only will be unable to employ his command
effectively,
but would create vacillation lack of confidence,
hesitation and indecision within the command itself.
The ability to make sound and timely decisions can be acquired by constant study
and by training in making estimates.
On the other hand,
when circumstance,
when circumstances dictate a change in plan,
the able leader will act promptly without fear that the command may consider
such action as of vacillation.
So yeah,
you've got to make good decisions.
And then if you make a bad decision,
you just say,
hey,
that was wrong.
We're moving to this other direction.
Now my boss,
let's roll.
Principle nine,
seek responsibility and develop a sense of responsibility among subordinates.
This is about ownership.
The leader must be quick to seize initiative in the absence of instructions from
his superior by seeking responsibility of the leader,
develops himself professionally and increases his potential ability.
Proper delegation of authority is a sound attribute of leadership.
The commander then holds his subordinate strictly responsible for the results
and rarely the methods of procedure.
So what he's saying there is a,
you tell people what to do,
not how to do it.
You let them figure out the methods of procedure,
such action by the commander in genders,
trust,
faith and confidence.
So when I give someone a mission and I don't tell him specifically every little
detail of how I want it done,
there's just let them run with it.
That means they know good,
I trust them and that develops trust back in my direction for me.
If it develops initiative and whole hearted cooperation,
reluctance to delegate authority often is the mark of retarded growth in
leadership.
So seek responsibility,
but more important,
give that responsibility,
give that ownership down the chain of command.
Principle 10 employ your command in accordance with its capabilities
to employ his command properly.
Leader must have a thorough knowledge of the tactical and administrative
capabilities and limitations of his command.
He must assign objectives that are possible of attainment.
That's a good one.
Sometimes I see business leaders,
you know,
they're all fired up and they throw things at their teams that are not
achievable and I'll say,
well,
do you think they can really pull it off?
Well,
I don't know if the ball,
you don't want to give them that good stretch goal and meanwhile,
no one thinks they can even hit the goal.
So they don't even try.
You know,
you can see this all day with kids.
If they,
if you give them something that's dead,
they,
that they figure out that they can't achieve it all,
they'll just stop trying.
And it's the same thing with adults.
It's human nature.
Makes Sense.
Is that what it's called?
The stretch goal?
Yeah.
That's what sales people and other people do.
But sales groups at companies,
they'll call it a stretch goal.
Liquid.
We,
we got our stretch goal.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
We've got a stretch goal.
We're going to sell for $80 billion in the next four weeks.
The teams like that means we're doing the do you know,
400 times what we've ever done in a full year.
We're going to do that in two weeks.
That's not realistic.
I'm just going to do what I normally do.
Yeah.
To do less than this may spell failure.
Okay.
In accomplishing the mission,
recurrent failure brings about collapse of morale,
a spree decor and efficiency.
So that's another thing.
When you give these goals that are unattainable and you do it repeatedly,
people start thinking,
well,
we're not even good enough.
It starts to hurt morale.
However,
on occasion when the situation demands,
men must be pushed without hesitation beyond,
they're considered capabilities in order to achieve a quick and cheap victory or
to avoid a costly defeat.
So yeah,
sometimes you got to dig in
and the last principle,
principle 11 when this is going to come as a big surprise,
take responsibility for your actions.
The commander of a unit is responsible for all his unit does or fails to do.
They didn't know about extreme ownership back in 1951 apparently.
Yeah,
I guess they called it something else.
They didn't come up with as good of a name trumped him with the name.
The leader recognizes and acknowledges this responsibility on all occasions.
Any effort to evade this responsibility destroys the bond of loyalty and respect
that must exist between the commander and his subordinates.
Take
responsibility,
take extreme ownership for your actions for everything the unit does or fails to
do.
You own it all.
All right,
so there's your 11 principles of leadership.
Now it gets into some leadership traits.
Leadership traits are human qualities that are of great value to the leader.
Possession of these leadership traits simplifies the task of applying leadership
principles and assist greatly in winning confidence,
respect and cooperation
and individual can benefit by studying the traits considered important to the
leader.
By careful self analysis and application,
he can develop those traits in which he is deficient and further strengthen the
ones in which he is strong.
So you got to look at yourself.
You got to see which one of these traits are good,
which ones are bad,
which one are you good at?
Which one are you weak at?
Need to figure those out.
A study of our nation's great military leaders reveals that none possessed all
the leadership traits to the maximum degree,
but that a weakness in some traits was more than compensated for by strength.
And others,
critical self analysis will enable an individual to realize the traits in which
he is strong and to capitalize upon them at the same time.
He must endeavor to improve those traits in which he is weak.
The following is a list of traits.
The following list of traits is by no means all inclusive,
but does contain those of paramount importance to the leader.
So this is a great list of traits,
alertness,
vigilance,
promptness and wide awakeness.
So you gotta be alert.
As a leader,
you gotta be in the game.
You ever seen a leader that's like not quite in the game?
Yes.
It's just not good,
right?
No,
you got it.
You got to be in the game.
If you're tired,
if you're napping,
you know if you're sleeping,
if you need a rest,
if you're,
if you're daydreaming.
You know what I mean?
You know what's funny is you,
you know how I have that tendency sometimes if people are talking to me and I'm
not interested in what they're saying and I know you complained about this.
Well,
Dean complains about this.
Yeah.
Uh,
leaf has made some comments about this.
They're like,
if you're not,
if you're saying to everybody,
I got everybody.
So,
but when I do that,
people don't think I'm not alert.
Right.
They think like he's,
he's just like,
he's alert on something else.
Yeah.
You checked out this jock Jocko does not care about what I'm saying right now.
So,
but it is rude and I,
it is a weakness of mine.
Well,
it's a weakness of mine for sure.
So do you do it on purpose?
No,
I don't think it's rude then.
That's
just how,
no,
it's rude.
It's rude for sure.
It's rude for sharing.
Can See it's route for sure.
I know that it makes,
I know that it's not a,
not a good thing to do.
I know that.
And I don't mean to do it.
Yeah.
That makes it better.
I think it's better.
Well then he can't,
obviously,
it's better that I'm not intentionally doing it.
It's not like,
it's not like you're in mid sentence and I just,
I just go,
you know what?
I just show you the palm and walk away.
Right.
I don't do that.
I just,
you'll like,
someone will be talking to me and I'll be thinking about something that I need
to be thinking about it.
All of a sudden I'll,
maybe I'll turn or all walk or whatever and yeah,
that's disrespectful man.
I shouldn't do that.
That's one of my weaknesses.
But what on the other hand,
what if I'm going off on some thing?
You know,
it's possible.
It is possible.
You are correct.
That is a possibility.
Yeah.
So I guess it's like,
it's a spectrum.
I mean your way on this side of the spectrum where I need to go off on some
thing and you know,
and you'll still sort of do that sometimes,
but I still,
right,
right.
But it still is not a good thing to,
it'd be better for me to say like,
hey man,
you know,
what can you tell me about this later?
Like when I'm 60
because I don't care about it right now and I'm not going to care about it for
another 15 years or whatever.
Okay,
so alertness.
Next one is bearing bearing denotes desirable physical appearance,
dress and department.
This is important.
Or like just how you,
how you present.
Good.
Right?
What's your bearing or you slouched over?
I went and worked.
I went in to talk to some underprivileged kids and these underprivileged kids
weren't,
I would say the type of kids they were,
they were underprivileged kids who were really smart and in a bad situation,
not under privileged kids who were not quite as smart and kind of just making
their way in that underprivileged world.
These kids were getting beat down by their world and I went there and talked to
him and I was going to talk about humility.
Right?
And as I kind of got towards the humility part,
I was,
I said to myself,
I don't need to talk to these people,
these kids about humility adult.
These kids are overly humble.
These kids are beat down.
These kids need confidence.
Right?
Right.
And what they needed was they needed to Barry,
right.
They needed to stand up straight.
Right.
That's what they needed.
They needed to sit in their chairs.
Or when they asked the question,
I started making them,
Hey,
when you asked me a question,
stand up,
stand up and ask the question.
I wasn't being a jerk.
And I was like,
hey,
we stand up.
You know,
let everyone see you.
Cause they're just,
their confidence was broken by life.
And so you're,
you're bearing is important.
And when someone comes and presents to you and they,
they don't seem,
they seem broken.
They seem unconfident.
Yeah.
Your bearings bearings really important.
So that means looking squared away,
that means shown,
you know,
that's why I t you bruiser everyone dressed in the proper uniform.
Everyone had a shaved head.
Everyone had,
you know,
everyone did the right things.
So that way when we went to talk to the army and the Marine Corps,
they didn't think these guys are idiots.
Yeah.
Next courage must be both physical and moral.
No real expansion needed on that one.
Decisiveness,
the ability to make decisions promptly and when indicated and announce them a
forte.
Dively concisely and clearly.
Dependability is the doing of one's duty without supervision.
Endurance,
both mental and physical is necessary to continue and complete.
Any reasonable task.
Enthusiasm is positive is the positive zeal or interest in the task at hand.
It is easily communicated to subordinates.
You know,
that's one thing that's so good in the military is you get to see examples of
when people are enthusiastic about a job.
It just changes everything,
right?
When you,
when you have people that are not enthusiastic and really all you need is one or
two people that are having a good time and in a soup tune,
you pretty much always have that.
You always have at least someone that's,
that's just gonna bring it ready to,
to get them ready to go,
ready to go.
And if it's not you today,
maybe it's you know,
Bill,
which apparently bill's been getting a lot of flack recently,
so we'll get bill some credit bills,
bills.
Bill has a good day and bill goes to make it happen and everyone sees the bills
crushing it and you're like,
ah,
you know what?
Let's do this.
Force is the ability to impose one's will upon another.
Now this is an interesting one,
right?
It,
it's an interesting one.
The ability to impose one's will upon another because that doesn't really mesh
too well with the persuasive leadership than I've been bragging to all about
about this book.
You know,
forces like,
hey,
that being said,
yeah,
I understand what they're talking about.
I understand that there's people that will not stop until they,
they have maneuvered into the position that they want to be in.
So I understand how forced,
and I understand how,
Ha let me put it this way.
If I have a seal platoon and I've got a task that needs to get done and there's
someone in the seal platoon that has a high level of force and I can say,
hey bill,
go make this happen.
And bill goes,
got it.
You know,
he's gonna make it happen.
Right?
Yeah.
So there,
and he might not necessarily use force as his primary tool to make it happen.
He might go and be butter someone up or get some,
you know,
massage some ego and make something happen that's still using force.
It's just using gay,
an indirect force.
So that's where I think we're talking about next is humility.
Okay.
Which is freedom,
arrogance,
and unjustifiable pride.
Talk about humility all the time.
Humor is the capacity to appreciate the many amusing or whimsical happenings of
our everyday life,
especially those which pertain to the leader himself.
So don't take yourself too seriously.
I did a video the other day,
like a Monday morning video you're talking about.
Yeah.
And it was April fool's day and I got super serious and I kind of went off April
fool's day is weak or whatever.
I just kind of went off of this big thing and a couple of people,
I think it was two people
responded with,
you know,
I couldn't even watch this.
You do.
There's nothing wrong with having fun.
I just said,
hey man,
watch the whole video.
I'm laughing at the end.
It's,
it's okay dude,
I get it.
Anything that triggered are so maybe they got triggered.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
you said so I think you posted something like a written thing about how you're
like,
Hey,
today is like one of those days where I need more recovery or something like
that.
Basically indicating that you are going to take a rest day or whatever and then
know,
put a post April fool's day.
That was what,
last year.
Oh No,
you're right.
I did do that this year,
which is weird.
I don't know why probably I always fall for those.
I'm like,
oh yeah,
I was thinking of when date or whatever and yeah,
and you did another one too.
I think it might've been last year and I was like totally falling for it.
April four last year I think I was in Montana and I was eating Moose tracks the
ice cream or that and that made a big joke and I was like,
Hey,
you know,
I've been eating Moose tracks and I just,
I'm,
I'm thinking maybe I've just been too extreme with his whole deal
and to delight.
No,
no.
Anyways,
so yes,
you've got to be able to,
you got to have built,
I think,
I think it's important.
It's not just having fun,
but the important part,
the most important part of humor is realizing that you yourself are going to be
the butt of jokes and that's okay.
Yeah.
And we were talking about that before where,
you know,
the guy who,
who can't take it and more so than they can't take it,
it's just like you feel uncomfortable joking around with him.
You know,
you can joke around everybody else in them,
but when they're around is kind of like,
hey,
we shouldn't really joke around as much.
And that sort of the dynamic one they're around.
Yeah.
And it's not even,
it's not even,
I shouldn't joke around.
I shouldn't joke around about that person.
That's what you're talking about.
Yeah,
because there's some people they love to have fun and then the minute the mirror
shines a dem or the light shines on them and they become the butt of the joke.
They don't like it at all.
And even if,
um,
even if they're like,
they don't respond in this negative will,
even if the person is more,
is just,
they just be quiet,
you know,
that kind of were like,
they don't necessarily like
getting mad,
but they're just making little,
they'd just get quiet.
Exactly.
It's like you just can sort of tell,
you know,
there's like a dynamic when you joke zone,
this wicked land,
no one wants you around,
man.
Sure we'll do the job boss.
Sure.
But man,
no one wants you around.
Go back into your eyes.
Keep your sense of humor,
especially about yourself.
I have,
I have a good time with that.
I have no issue with that.
You know,
another thing I think is if,
if you,
if somebody says something to you,
like makes a joke about you and it hurts you,
that's,
that's your ego and there's probably truth in what they're saying and so you
need to pay attention to it.
How does ego feed into insecurity?
Because you know how like,
cause a lot of them is insecurity cause it,
it over compensates.
Yeah.
So if I'm insecure about,
if I'm insecure of welfare,
I'm insecure about my leadership capabilities that I try and blow up and act
like a big leader.
That's basically it.
Because your ego is like,
Hey,
I can't,
like I can't deal with this little like shortcoming in whatever way that's in my
mind or whatever.
Right.
So I'm gonna you overcompensate.
That's where you see it.
And then if someone jokes around about it,
it kind of like shoe shines light on it.
Ooh,
you don't like that stinks.
Yeah,
but it's all on your own.
Well,
most of the time it didn't like in your own mind,
you know how bad it is.
Next one initiative is the willingness to act in the absence of orders and to
offer well-considered recommendations for the improvement of the command.
Awesome.
Got To have initiative.
Next is integrity is the honesty and moral character of the leader that must be
unquestioned.
Intelligence is the intellect of the leader,
which must be adequate to match to the problems presented by his level.
Command judgement is the power of the mind to weigh various factors and arrive
at a wise decision and you know what?
They talked about making decisions and one thing that I didn't really talk
about,
I didn't emphasize too much is how do you get better decision making?
You get better at decision making by training you better decision making by
putting yourself into situations where,
hey,
this is what's happening and Oh,
here's the decision I'm going to make.
Oh,
it was completely wrong.
Cool.
I just learned not to make that type of decision before.
Let me try it again.
When I was running a trade at out here for the west coast,
that was the whole goal was to put guys into situations.
They had to make a decision.
They would make wrong decisions all the time.
And then I knew they would not make that wrong decision again because once you
make it and you feel it and it stings and your whole platoon is covered in paint
ball and they're murdered,
well you won't make that bad decision again.
And that was the goal.
Uh,
justice is being equitable and impartial in bestowing favors and punishment.
Loyalty must extend both up and down.
A leader cannot expect loyalty from his subordinates unless he is conspicuously
loyal to them and to his superiors as a big one.
Right?
If you're running around talking smack about your bosses,
that's showing your team that debt,
you're not
loyal to him.
And we'll,
we could go down the whole road of,
if I have a horrible boss,
does that mean I just am a yes man?
No,
I'll frame things for the guys to make them realize,
look,
I know there's some shortfalls here,
but we got who we got.
What we're going to do is build a great relationship with them and then we'll,
we'll,
we'll at least have some saying what's going on.
So if you see me and it seems like I'm just trying to,
trying to massage my boss,
his ego.
Guess what I'm trying to do,
trying to massage my boss is eagle.
I want to have a great relationship with them so I can take care of us.
And besides what do we want to do lose influence over him.
Do you want him to not listen to anything?
I say no.
So that's what I'm doing
because if you just,
if your boss is an idiot and all you do is support them a hundred percent your
guys are going to start thinking you're an idiot and that's not good.
Yeah.
So there's a fine line.
That's a tough one to walk.
Yeah.
That's tough one to walk,
man.
That's good man.
It's like a full,
it's like a full disclosure situation where it's like,
hey,
I get it.
I get what you guys are saying or whatever,
but this is why we're doing it kind of thing.
Because like how you say,
if you follow the boss who's,
who's a quote unquote idiot and then you seem like it it.
And then on the other hand,
if you're like,
be nice to the boss and you know being nice and then when you go to your middle
and like it's so dumb.
It's like talking kind of behind his back.
You're like,
oh,
you're two faced a little bit and you don't have to say,
Hey,
the Boston media,
we're just trying to,
I'm just trying to butter them up.
No,
you say like,
hey listen,
the boss doesn't always see things the way I see him,
but you know what?
He is the boss and what I'm trying to do is build a good relationship with them.
I'm trying to do a good job,
said he listens to what I say so that I can influence them and steer them in the
right direction on some of these things so that we can accomplish our mission
better.
I just got asked this by a swat guy.
I was out with the police out North Carolina in,
in Charlotte and you know it was the typical question of what do you do when
your boss is telling you to do something that you don't necessarily agree with
and it's like,
okay,
we can talk about that.
And I went down the whole road because it is a whole road because if your boss
is telling you something that's insignificant telling you to do something that
really doesn't make that much of difference,
then you just do it and you've built that relationship a little bit more.
They take you to do something else as a kind of insignificant.
Maybe it's not the smartest thing.
Maybe there's a more efficient way.
Is that really what you want to fall on your sword for and create a
dysfunctional relationship with your boss?
No.
You're like,
hey boss,
got it.
Sounds like a good idea.
Hey,
we'll make it happen.
And then that goes on and you continue to build relationships.
So then eventually when your boss tells you to do something that is actually
unsafe or unsound or an ethical,
unethical is a different story.
Cause if someone's telling you do something unethical,
well it's actually not a different story because if they're telling you to do
something unethical and you say,
no,
I will,
I will not do that.
They go,
cool,
you're fired.
And now who's going to come in?
Yes ma'am.
And now no one's protecting the guys.
So,
so yes,
you don't just,
you don't just give
blind loyalty,
but at the same time you try and build relationships.
That's what you do.
Yeah.
In jacked your influence later,
whatever.
Right?
In the big,
you put it a real good way a few times where I think it was just at the monster,
I'm not sure,
I don't know why he said it exactly,
but how you were like,
Hey,
if I'm a leader and my guy,
and this goes both ways by the way.
So if I'm a leader and I have a hundred percent solution to a problem and then,
but my guy comes in and he has a 75 80% solution,
I'm going with 80 right.
So it could be in these,
in the situation where your,
your question example of what if I disagree with my boss.
Is that why you're disagreeing?
Because you're over here with hundreds and he's over here with eight 85 or even
90 sometimes there's like look how much,
I mean,
you know,
so I disagree with your plan cause you're,
it could be that.
Got It boss.
Let's do it.
Yeah,
I'm good.
That goes up and down the chain of command.
You are correct.
The classic example of this is in band of brothers.
When Dick winters gets tasked,
his guys to go over and do reconnaissance across the river,
they go,
they do the reconnaissance,
they get in a firefight,
they lose a guy.
It's a disaster to come back.
And then Dick Winters boss says do it again tomorrow night.
And the,
by the way,
the water like all but over at this point.
And he says,
okay boss.
And then he goes and tells his guys,
Hey,
go and go in the cellar of one of these buildings and sit there for four hours
and then come back and I'm going to tell him that you guys didn't see anything.
And that's what they do.
So that is disobeying an order.
That is,
that's what it is.
But it wasn't the right thing to do.
Yes it was.
Why would you put more guys at risk and to say,
boss,
I totally disagree.
I'm not doing it.
He just said,
okay fine,
you're fired.
Winners gimme another a young officer and I'll make him go do it.
And the other guy who's trying to get up the chain of command,
he does it and then gets another guy killed.
Yeah.
So there are situations and of course is that like the norm?
No,
I'm not saying that's the norm.
I'm saying in an extreme case,
the war's almost over.
We just lost a guy.
This,
this reconnaissance has no impact on the war whatsoever.
If they weren't even going to planning to go and fight,
it was just a recon just to just to do it.
And so it was like,
no,
we're not doing that.
Yeah.
So
that's it.
Loyalty,
try and build that loyalty up and down the chain of command.
Sympathy is the capacity of sharing the feelings of those with whom one is
associated.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't like to talk about feelings very much actually you don't.
But the thing in practice,
like you do that surprisingly good and I don't want to say supporting like I'm
surprised but sometimes I'm pretty impressed with your sympathetic abilities,
I guess empathy,
right?
Empathy.
Like I understand where you're coming from and I,
you know,
I always use the word perspective and I think maybe it's just because it's a
more of a tougher word,
you know?
Then feelings.
Sure.
But I'll say,
hey,
you need to cause,
cause let's face it,
it won't sound right if I say,
hey listen,
platoon commander,
you need to really just,
just reach out and touch the feelings of your men.
Right.
That doesn't sound right.
Does it from,
no,
it doesn't sound right.
Factually.
Can I say,
Hey,
listen,
between commander,
you need to understand the perspective that you guys are seeing this from.
Yeah.
You need to see that they're thinking you're just driving them to do something
that doesn't matter or whatever.
It's the same thing,
but I use tougher works cause you know that's how I roll.
Yeah.
You know when I'll come to you with like this conundrum or something going on in
roles,
but you're talking about with humans now with people.
Yeah.
And even you,
your sympathy kind of towards me where it may be on the surface you might sort
of expect you to be like,
like,
oh man up or you know something like this,
but you'll like,
you'll kind of give me my do like sympathy.
Even with what you say,
like you'll,
you'll sympathize.
Like you'll be like,
hey,
you're like man,
that is a bummer.
Or whatever,
you know,
like whatever the words you say.
Well the thing is if I didn't do that then I you have,
you won't want to listen to what I'm actually about telling you to do.
Yeah.
Because sometimes the solution is hard.
Right.
Sometimes the solutions to these things are hard.
And
if you don't open up that door a little bit to build a little something,
then you're just not,
you're just going to say,
oh yeah,
it,
what,
what you'll think is I'm not Jocko and what he says doesn't apply to me.
Yes,
yeah,
that's what's happening.
Or you need to just cut away or whatever.
You need to just tell that person no more like,
no,
I have,
you have,
man,
that's a rough situation to be in.
I think what's going to happen here,
I mean,
if you view weigh it out,
the only real solution is for you to kind of back away from that scenario.
You know what I mean?
So it kind of brought you in,
made you think that I'm human and then we'll,
there we go.
I'm thinking,
uh,
next tact is the ability to deal with subordinates and superiors in an
inappropriate manner without giving offense.
Boy,
that seems like so simple,
but man,
tact people got mad or didn't get mad.
What did I say?
I said tact trumps the truth on a podcast whenever.
Yeah.
And some people when all Sam Harris on me,
no,
you will never,
ever.
And then I brought up 48 examples of where,
oh,
so what you should do is just be truthful at all times.
No ma'am.
Um,
you know,
there's times where what I thought you,
your performance I thought was pathetic and embarrassing in disastrous.
Yeah.
And yet you're in the position,
I need you to do a good job.
I need your morale to stay high.
I see that you're beat down yourself.
So instead of telling you all those things,
I preemptively tell you,
hey,
look,
this was a really hard task.
And I know it was challenging and you probably weren't quite ready because I
didn't give you enough information.
But here's some things I think will help next time around.
Right.
I didn't tell you the full truth.
I mean,
I didn't lie to you either.
So maybe that's,
so maybe that's the difference between Sam Harris and Jordan,
because what Jordan Peterson says is tell the truth or at least don't lie.
So there's,
there's a little gray area between those two.
Let's spark another debate between those two guys.
Yeah.
Shoot.
I kind of in a way agree with both,
if I even understand them 100% but yeah,
like the,
you know,
cause there's all kinds of lies and the lying by omission.
And then the other one they say white lies and then they say,
but uh,
I think it's black lies.
What is that I for?
But lying by omission or whatever,
it's like you're telling the truth,
but you're leaving out stuff to kind of lead them in a certain direction or
whatever to make them think certain stuff.
There's,
then there's that,
you know,
so it's like,
all right,
it Kenny,
like I said,
if you get into a lot of gray area there,
and I guess there's times where,
you know,
the classic example that I guess Sam Harris talks about is,
should you tell your wife when your wife comes out and says,
do I look fat?
What you should say is yes,
maybe no,
that enthusiast.
Right,
right,
right.
But to his point,
if you don't say that,
well then yeah,
you let her,
you can let her continue on whatever path she's on.
But that's not good.
And ends up in a bad way.
So,
so a little bit of credit there,
but to give a little push back on Sam,
if you are just straight up a jerk about it.
Well guess what?
We haven't done what we just talked about,
which is I haven't built a little bridge and connected and said,
you know,
and so now all she's going to do daily and then now we have an anger situation
now and they might not listen to anything that you're going to say and now we
might ruin a relationship based on the fact that we went to hardcore.
Now,
to Sam's point,
if you don't ever indicate any kind of truth and you just let a person continue
on a path that uh,
bad for them and is bad for their,
in this case,
their weight,
well then that's not good either.
But the key component,
if you have tact and you build the relationship,
because basically I think I had this conversation with Lafe a little while ago.
You know,
when you're dealing with someone,
when you're dealing with a team,
you're either forwarding and improving the relationship or you know,
you could be neutral or you're making it go backwards.
What we want to be doing is improving the relationship at a minimum.
We want to remain neutral and every other aspect of going backwards in the
interrelationship is bad.
So we're business partners and we have a,
we have a discussion about something.
I want the result of that discussion to be that our relationship improved.
Yeah.
At a minimum I wanted to be neutral and worst case we've actually gone backwards
cause that's not not good.
So now when you start talking about your spouse,
we want that relationship to improve.
We don't want it to go backwards and neutral is a minimum.
So when we,
when we get asked the question,
do I look fat?
And the answer is absolutely yes.
That's going to be,
that's good.
That's not going to lead to,
that's not going to lead to the,
the,
it's not going to lead to your spouse respecting and listening to what you're
saying.
It's going to lead your spouse saying,
oh,
you're a jerk.
Yeah.
You don't know how hard it is for me.
You're not part of my team.
You're on a different team.
And therefore,
since we're on different teams,
I don't need to listen to anything that you say.
Yeah.
So there's better way to go about it then.
That's called tact.
Yeah.
And then to have these talks with my brother,
she'd from time to time.
And so an example is like if you,
like if you're a corrector,
you know,
guy like you use a word wrong or sale,
we're pronounce a word wrong,
like the guy who's so quick to always correct in front of people,
whatever.
You know you're a corrector.
Usually those correctors people,
those correct.
Or people are there.
Right.
You know,
and then they're telling the truth.
It's true.
It's correct.
You know?
So what they're saying is correct and they're lonely
because look no tact.
Right.
So that what they're saying is correct.
What they're doing is not correct.
Like you shouldn't do that.
And that's like essentially what tact is.
You know,
it,
it's not like you were saying,
hey,
did I say that right?
And you're like,
hey,
you know,
you didn't say that.
Right.
And it's different to to pull someone aside and say,
hey man,
hey,
just want to let you know you mispronounce this word right now.
Yeah,
there's an eye.
I don't like the fact that I mispronounced words and I do it on this podcast on
a fairly regular basis.
And occasionally someone will hit me up and say,
hey you,
you mispronounce this word or that word.
Someone sent me a,
uh,
either an email or something the other day that was like,
yeah,
you mispronounced words.
This would not be that hard to fix.
You should pay attention or whatever.
Something like that was pretty,
pretty,
uh,
pretty straight forward.
Right.
And I was like,
yeah,
you know,
that's a bummer.
Um,
cause the thing is,
yeah,
I don't like mispronouncing words and yet the corrective measures for not
mispronouncing words.
Okay.
Is it,
for instance,
if we're going and I'll,
all of a sudden I'm saying something wrong and I'm like,
hold on,
let me go back.
Let me interrupt.
What I'm my thought pattern.
Let me interrupt what I'm saying to try and figure out if I pronounce this thing
right or wrong,
I lean,
it's better to just flow and get corrected later.
So I apologize for my mispronounced words.
Yeah,
my bust.
I should do a better job.
Like that guy who emailed me that,
I'm sorry.
Uh,
the last one is on the selfishness.
Unselfish unselfishness is the study to avoidance of caring for or providing for
one's own comfort or advantage at the expense of others.
Anytime that you as the leader are getting the good deal,
while you're people are getting shafted,
they notice it and they don't like it.
They didn't like it at all.
So,
and it's weird because the military does that.
That's the way the military operates.
The officers get paid more money,
the officers live in officer's quarters.
The EAD dogs are down in the bilge of the ship and the hot,
nasty and just that's the way it is.
So there's a little bit of that,
but there's,
there's a saying in the military rank has its privileges and it's sort of a
snobby thing to say in my opinion.
But anyways,
I guess the point I was going to make is when I had,
when I had officers that were,
that I really had a lot of respect for and they would always downplay that and
never rub it in your face basically because there is a separation,
hey,
these guys are in a leadership position,
they have more responsibility and therefore they're getting paid more and
they're getting treated a little bit elevated.
But when someone would rub that in your face,
boy that just does make you mad.
What's the expression when you know your boss or you're with someone who
outranks you?
It's the,
not necessarily,
it's not in the military,
I don't think,
but it's something like in this story it's like I have a few more letters you
might title or something like that,
or a few more now.
Like especially like my title has a few more letters in it,
whatever.
It's something like that.
Oh yeah.
My boss told me that one time.
Dang.
Yeah,
like straight up like I was,
this is in the club days.
I think I told you this tells you that straight up.
Yeah.
Well here's the thing.
So in,
in our club there was an area you couldn't go in if you're,
he'd had a dress code in this area.
It was like a dumb Jesco too,
by the way.
But,
and we all knew it.
Everyone knew it,
that it was kind of dope.
He was like,
you couldn't wear it.
Jeans.
Yeah,
like jeans.
What about origin jeans?
Way before dinner jeans,
unless you couldn't wear jeans,
so whatever.
So one day I was,
it was like I wasn't working and I was wearing jeans.
All my friends were not wearing jeans there with there.
So I kind of go,
right.
And then my boss was working and he said,
hey,
like you can't be in here with jeans on.
So I'm like,
all right,
Dang.
Okay.
You know,
in front of everybody,
but cool man.
All right.
So I left and then it was like a week later he was off.
Same deal.
That is the roles were reversed.
Oh yeah.
He's up there genes full
on like doing it and kick him out.
Jokingly I said,
hey,
you can't be here with jeans,
you know,
and that's what he told me.
He said,
I have a few more letters in my title day.
He still mad at your
district level for him to go up or down?
Well yeah,
I'll put it this way.
It would have went down if it wasn't that zero already.
So yeah,
when it went down.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
Be Unselfish.
And the other thing is when you do on selfish things like that,
people notice it.
And if you're doing them,
because hey,
if they also noticed this,
if you're doing something on selfish because you want credit for it,
that doesn't work either straight.
It's like if you're like op there,
you know,
if you're doing something because you want that outcome,
if you're,
when you do something for your troops,
you should do it because you care about your troops,
not because you're trying to build up a good,
uh,
yeah.
Good image with your troops.
Sick to know,
man,
you guys have been busting your ass for me and I'm going to handle this thing
over here so you guys can go get some time off.
Go.
It's not,
it's not,
hey,
if I do this thing for those guys,
Dell,
Dell increased a liking me more.
Don't do that.
You can tell when guys do that to men.
So everyone can tell.
People don't think people think,
no one notices.
You know,
they noticed that more than the good.
Did what?
Okay,
what about this Phil?
What about if they,
um,
you know,
highlight and this is a common one where,
where you make a donation,
right to whatever charity or cause or whatever.
Right?
And you said,
we chose,
you know,
and they celebrate.
We just made this donation to this charity or whatever.
Like how about that?
Cause that's what you're,
it's kind of doing,
you're publicizing well,
okay,
I get that people do that.
And then you take that and you compare that to someone that says,
oh well,
like they investigate some politician and then they go,
there's politicians are,
you know,
a horrible person.
And then investigate them.
And they find out that he's donated millions of dollars to all these different
charities,
but never said a word about it.
Your respect for that person goes up as opposed to someone that's donated
millions of dollars and he's like,
Hey,
let's do another photo shoot of me donating.
There's the big giant,
you know,
four by six check,
Eh,
$100,000 thing on it.
It's at the front of their website.
Front page.
Yeah.
So at the end of the day it's more about like,
okay,
so what message was sort of sent and received?
Like he's the message is the front running message.
The fact that I am so generous that I donate and I do these things,
or is the message that,
oh my gosh,
it's so good now that this charity,
whatever it gets the help that they want kind of thing.
You know what people underestimate all the time.
People underestimate
how well other people can see what's going on.
I get sleep,
I see people and I say,
man,
do you really think that anybody you're fooling anyone?
And it usually happens,
usually happens with people that are,
well,
they're obviously,
they're smart,
but they're there so they think they're so smart,
right?
They think they're so smart.
And I always think to myself,
man,
do you really think that anyone is,
do you think they're getting this over on anyone?
So we make these mistakes.
Like this is a classic example where you do something cool but you're just doing
it because you want that credit.
Everybody sees that.
Everybody sees and goes,
Nah,
yeah,
he's just doing that to try and look cool.
Because you know why they know that?
Because two days ago you screwed them and now you're trying to be all cool.
But people make that mistake all the time.
I'm a hyper sensitive to what other people are like how they perceive.
I realized that any facade that I put up is just a,
it's anyone basically.
Anyone can say,
sure you might fall a couple people,
but people just look at you go,
that's garbage.
I don't believe you,
but it's in a tea and I'm agreeing with you,
but I,
I'm not agreeing with you and being like you and I don't do that,
bro.
I to me,
everyone does that.
Literally everyone does it.
And literally everyone is,
is not like less aware how you say,
it's like we're under what?
What'd you say you ate?
Underestimate.
Just how much.
Yeah.
So as to meet everyone and that's why the most,
that's why the important thing is when you're doing things,
do them from the place of honesty.
Right.
Do you know I'll,
I'll say things like,
I'm trying to think of a good example where I'll say,
hey,
you got to do this,
and then I'll say,
you've got to do this now.
See what you got to actually meet.
We'll just take it.
I mean,
the real easy example is like take ownership or something,
right?
I'll say,
yeah,
you got to take ownership of that,
but I'm not saying,
Hey,
take ownership of that,
because then everyone will think that you're a Marger and then no one will be
mad at you.
No,
that's not why you're doing it.
You're taking ownership because you have to actually believe that you're the one
that's in charge of that thing,
that you were truly responsible for.
What had happened when somebody asks me if,
if I would've taken extreme ownership,
if I would've gotten fired,
would that have changed my view?
It's like no.
My view was an,
is that as the leader,
I'm responsible for everything that happens.
Truly responsible.
Not,
not.
Hey,
oh,
I read in a book,
I read in the,
the FM 10 tack 22 that,
that I'm supposed to be responsible.
So I'm gonna raise my hand and say I'm responsible.
No.
You have to truly believe in it.
In that thing.
Yeah.
And,
and what's good is if you can do that exercise with yourself and say yourself,
wait a second,
why am I saying this?
Do I truly believe what I'm saying?
And if you don't,
you have to say,
wait a second.
This isn't,
that's not right.
It's not right to do that.
You need to actually believe what you're saying.
Yeah.
And then
after you realize that you,
you know you're not right,
you look up and realize that everyone else is already
there.
Everyone else already sees that.
You don't believe.
Here's another one.
When guys,
when a girl breaks up with a guy and the guy's all heartbroken,
right?
And they'll say,
you know,
I don't know what to do and now and I'll say,
look,
you have to not,
you have to not care.
And so what they think,
I'm saying his act like they don't care.
But I'm not saying that.
I'm saying you have to not care.
You have to actually not care.
You have to actually say,
hey,
this person was not who I thought they were an I don't care that they're gone
and I'm going to move on.
If you say that that's your best possible outcome.
If all you're doing is acting that way and it still drives you crazy,
it goes back to what we just said.
If you're just acting that way,
guess what?
The female in the situation absolutely knows that you're just trying to act that
way.
They have the,
I mean,
human beings have a certain level of perception of,
of the way other people's emotions are like you can perceive it unconsciously.
They perceive it unconsciously or consciously.
You know,
it's like you're like,
I have a dog,
my dog can kind of know what I'm thinking.
And that's a damn dog with the brain.
Like the size of a walnut or whatever.
How big a big a dog's brain is,
right.
Not Big.
My dog can't speak English.
Right.
But my dog,
if I come home and I,
I go,
I act a certain way.
Like he knows it.
Yeah.
And so when you act like when you're acting like you don't care,
that girl can see that you care and it doesn't work.
You have to actually not care when you are trying to do something good for your
troops cause you want to win score points with them.
Yeah.
They know that when you're trying to prop up.
So,
so this is,
okay,
this is a good example.
When I said,
Hey,
I'm trying to build a relationship with a boss.
That's why I'm going to act this way.
Right.
That's different cause that boss is going to say,
oh he's just trying to butter me up.
It's like,
no,
actually,
oh Bossy,
you want it done that way.
I believe that's the best thing we can do is try and get it done that way.
So here I go,
I'm gonna make it happen.
It's not,
hey,
I'm going to skate around and sneak around and try and fool.
You know I'm going to believe in what I'm doing.
Yeah.
I'm going to believe that you have some higher intention that you're focused on
and that's cool with me.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
That thing you have to take it to the next level,
man.
You have to take it to the next level.
You've got to believe what you're doing.
You've got to believe it in when you don't.
People know every assume that everyone knows.
It brought my brother we were talking to with me,
Greg Macintyre and my brother yesterday.
A great treat for whatever great chain.
And we're basically con like telling my brother,
hey,
like come back to Jujitsu.
He's been out of the game for awhile and then,
so he's,
he's making up this total story,
God and our to hear it.
And you know,
he's good at those debates,
you know?
And he's like,
it's always about this
and this and this and like me and Greg chain or like,
not really saying that much stuff.
He didn't be like two of his excuses that he knows since he's like sort out of
shape.
Right.
Or is the,
since he's actually wait to get back in shape,
that's what we were asking.
But when you ask it direct like that,
it sounds dumb,
you know,
so he's like,
no.
Well it's,
no,
it's not that.
It's,
you know,
so if I'm like so exhausted,
I like,
I like training and I like kind of conversating with it with everybody at the
end and stuff like that.
So if I'm like so exhausted from training,
not only is that experience kind of diminished,
then I'm too exhausted to have like a home,
a good conversation.
He said it way more.
Like,
could you laugh at them?
I will,
Bro,
if I wanted him to.
Yes,
I was laughing on the inside talking about this.
Right?
Yes.
And well,
the good thing is,
well Kel,
okay,
so me and,
and he was right as Greg was sort of leaving,
right?
So I'm looking at Greg's face and Greg has that look on his face that we all
kind of get,
but Greg really get to that tastes kind of like,
all right bro,
whatever you say kind of thing.
I'm totally not believing right.
And I'm their madness.
I'm like,
Brad,
can you hear yourself?
Like that's not even a believable thing,
you know?
Can you be so exhausted that you can't talk afterwards?
Can you do that?
Especially,
I'm sure you can if you ran a,
I don't know,
a hundred marathons with no legs.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
he,
he can't put it down there.
And we all know that.
So anyway,
so,
so Greg sort of leaves and leaves it at that and I'm sitting there like kind of
looking at him and I was like,
just like,
all right,
thanks.
That's,
that's not true.
You know,
we,
I know why you're not going to go,
it's not a big deal.
You know,
we have friends that do that same thing like,
oh yeah,
sure I'll be back,
but I just don't,
I don't want to go tomorrow because of this and that and this.
And were like,
Bro,
those aren't even like applicable excuses.
And he was like,
he's like,
you're right.
He's like,
You're right.
100% right.
100 he totally admitted it.
He back on the map because he was not here today.
No,
no.
Get back on the mat.
He got good quick to that.
And that's kind of part of the whole picture.
You know,
it's like your waist almost.
You think that he will,
he learned,
learned anything from you just by being your twin brother?
No,
no,
I don't think so.
It's kind of seemed that way to me.
Although his game is very different from yours.
Yeah.
And maybe from like Troy,
he's like has an analytical mind,
you know?
So if like if I do it,
like if he asks,
oh here's another thing.
Yes.
Kind of indirectly from being my twin brother.
So me and him can communicate like spot on.
It's like we won't run into misunderstandings very often.
So if he has,
if he's lying about not training Jujitsu,
that was without weakness.
You were talking about you underestimating other perception.
I was hit that which he has obviously like we all do,
but yeah,
so if he has a question or he hears me talking about some something Jujitsu
wise,
he picks up it I think in that
way real quick.
And you know he's,
you know how to explain things really well to him because you have 40 years of
common language and experience to say,
Hey,
remember when I do this or hey,
remember in football on that or hey,
remember when whatever you've got all this stuff he can communicate through to
the tone.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
So yeah,
so I'd say there's the,
there's that,
you know,
but yeah,
he did.
He got the interesting thing about underestimating the way that everyone else
thinks is when you do that,
you first of all,
it's there.
They know.
And if you actually just live your life in a way that you're not trying to put
up fronts and your life is going to be better.
And if you live your life thinking that,
guess what,
at a minimum people are going to,
someone's going to know that this is a front.
If you do that.
It's kind of like when I told the,
the told a bunch of soldiers,
officers that they had a psychopath in their platoon.
I'm like every,
if you're,
if you've got 40 get,
I've went through this with Jordan where I asked him,
I said,
hey,
as I said,
if you have 40 people in a military unit,
in a platoon,
in an infantry platoon,
is one of them a sadist?
And he's like,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
And then I,
he said one in a hundred is good,
but in the military you've already eliminated a bunch of,
you know,
we are.
Yeah,
you've eliminated all nonsales cause there's no,
there's no one that's like not at least has some tendency to,
to be able to kill people.
Right.
Those people are in the platoon.
So you've eliminated a bunch of people that have zero chance of being a sadist.
They're not in there.
So one out of 40 is not bad it.
So if you treat your platoon as if you have a sadist in there,
then you'll eliminate that problem from getting out of hand.
So that's what you do.
So if you treat your life as if people will see through the lies and the fronts
that you're trying to put up for them,
you'll do better in life and you'll have a better platoon and you'll have a
better life.
That's good.
All right.
Leadership techniques.
It is important to note that in small units,
the leader can influence and direct his men through close personal contact.
Whereas in large units,
he must rely in great measure upon his staff and subordinate commanders to
assist them in making his leadership effective.
The larger the unit,
the more complex the problems of leadership,
but the greater cause,
the greater become the means available to the commander to assist him in the
exercise.
It was leadership.
So as you grow,
problems get more complex,
but you end up,
when you have more people,
you have more tools.
The larger unit commander must consider carefully the leadership aspect of all
basic policies,
which he prescribes or tolerates.
Okay.
This is what's interesting.
So we work with companies that grow really quickly,
especially nowadays in the startup world and the tech world.
And this is where they have a tough time transitioning because when you're in a
room,
you're not in an office and you got six people in there,
guess what?
You're leadership is really easy,
right?
You're,
you're talking to,
you know him,
you communicate with them.
It gets to 20 people.
Okay?
It's a little bit tricky,
but still,
you're all in a room.
You're meeting,
you're seeing each other every day,
30 40 hey,
guess what?
We're still all pretty much in a room.
Everyone's having lunch.
We're still a unit.
All of a sudden it kicks out 200200300 and this is where if you don't insert
good decentralized command,
good leadership tactics in there,
that's where these tech companies were.
And it's not just tech companies that any growing company loses it,
they lose it because they haven't put the command structure in place.
So that the vision of the commander and the vision of the leadership gets
distilled all the way down through the chain of command.
And now you have people do and things that they shouldn't be doing.
And,
and,
and I don't necessarily mean they're doing something illegal.
I'm saying they're doing things that don't support the strategic goals of the
company and it's a problem.
But as those companies grow,
what they don't realize is just like this book says,
you have more tools that you can put into place.
You've gotta,
you've gotta,
you've got a communications department inside your company whose job is internal
communications.
So you could be making what you could be making videos and explain to people
what's going on and given an update.
And you can,
you can do all those things.
You have that capability.
You have VTCs,
right?
You've got video calls,
you can make you,
you've got subordinate leadership that can go out there and get in the field and
make things known.
So there's a way to overcome these problems if you address,
if you don't address them and you can,
you think,
if you think you can keep leading a 2000 person organization as if you were
leading 20 people,
you're going to have a major issues and then it's not gonna work.
It's not going to work
back to the book.
Over a period of time,
the leader will develop techniques of his own,
which will be better suited to his own personality in which he himself will be
able to employ effectively.
So yeah,
you're all going to get your own little leadership techniques.
And what's I'm telling you where I'm really lucky is I've worked with so many
different leaders that I just don't know my techniques.
I say,
Hey,
you know,
what's a good thing to do here?
My buddy bill used to have an issue with us and you could,
you know,
so that's kind of Nice.
Now here are some,
uh,
leadership techniques.
These are leadership techniques that apply back to these principles.
These are applicable to all leaders.
Okay?
So when it comes to knowing your job,
principal want wanna know your job.
Seek a well rounded military education through attendance at service schools and
through regular independent reading research and study.
So how do you know your job?
You study another one.
Keep abreast of the latest techniques in the field of communication in order.
Facilitate control of your unit and disseminate information.
Three,
seek out and foster association with capable leaders.
Observe and study their actions and application of leadership techniques for
broadened your field of knowledge through association with officers and men of
other armed services.
Five seek the opportunity to apply knowledge through exercise.
A command.
Real leadership is acquired only through constant practice.
Six avoid over specialization in too narrow field.
Seven,
keep abreast of current military developments.
Eight,
familiarize yourself with capabilities and limitations of all elements of your
command by study and through frequent visits to subordinates.
So that's cool.
No your job.
And I'll tell you what,
one thing that's impressive as I get to work with a lot of leaders and some of
these leaders come up through their industry and man,
they are knowledgeable.
It's impressive,
it's impressive.
But
where the shortfall is there,
they're super knowledgeable about their field,
but they don't have the leadership knowledge.
Gotcha.
So that's what's beneficial about things like this.
Podcasts like extreme ownership,
like dichotomy,
leadership,
like the putting this information where people can actually read it and
understand that they can study because they know their job,
they know their technical field.
You know,
that's another thing with e f Overwatch right now is like we're bringing in
people that don't necessarily have the technical skill inside of a field,
but they have the leadership experience.
And it's a lot easier to teach someone in a technical skill than it is to teach
them leadership.
Because to get leadership,
the only way you get better leadership is leadership.
So we're very,
it's been very successful so far and,
and now we're starting to see employers that say they were a little,
you know,
you're hesitant because you think,
how do you know anything about whatever.
How do you know,
how can someone that's not from this field lead in this field?
Give the person an overview of what the,
what the field is.
Yeah.
And then they take their 22 years,
24 years,
26 years of real leadership experience and they apply it.
Yeah.
It's kind of like the human resource department a little bit in a,
in a small amount of,
right.
Like where,
what about HR?
Hr,
yes.
Legal.
You know,
you have this department that they don't really know anything about software or
nothing like that
and that's your bakery.
That's a big deal when people are working together,
you know,
kind of thing.
Yeah.
Good,
good,
good analogy.
Okay.
Here's some things and techniques for principal to know yourself and seek self
improvement.
Ah,
one,
analyze yourself objectively to determine the strong and weak points of your
character.
You could make that into a little drill,
right?
Actually,
look,
actually go down that list of characteristics and say,
which where are you at?
Yeah.
To recognize your weak points and make an effort to overcome them.
Three,
solicit when appropriate.
That candid opinions of others as to how you can make the most of your desirable
qualities and eliminate your undesirable ones.
Be.
Because when you asked that question,
if you ask it honestly,
you're going to get some answers.
You don't want to hear what your weak points.
Yeah.
No one wants to hear about those.
We do not even from themselves,
from themselves.
And it's,
it's so rare that someone truly wants to hear what they screwed up.
It's,
it just doesn't hardly exist.
Yeah.
So,
so what that means is everyone knows that and since everyone knows that they are
not going to give you an honest feedback.
So when you say,
hey,
how'd I do on that last task?
They go,
Oh man,
you did good.
They're lying.
They're not even being tactful.
They're telling a lie.
They're telling a lie to you.
Cause if they,
if they wanted to be tactful,
they gets to be tactful and say,
Hey,
you know what?
I know it was a tough project and you pulled it off,
which was commendable.
But there were some definite areas for improvement.
And he know what,
luckily I kept a list.
Let's go through it.
Boom.
Next profit by studying the causes for past success or failure of other leaders,
past and present.
Develop a genuine interest in people.
Acquire the human touch.
Practice the golden rule.
Mastered the art of good writing and speaking.
How do you do that?
Write and speak and read and listen.
And last one,
cultivate cordial relations with members of other arms and services and with
civilians.
Cool.
That's how you get to know yourself.
Some things,
some techniques for knowing your knowing your men.
Principle three,
know your men and look out for their welfare.
Number one,
see the members of your command and let them see you.
Stay locked up in the ivory tower.
Be Friendly and approachable.
Approachable,
yeah.
Important,
important.
Develop an intimate knowledge and understanding of your subordinates through
personal contact and available records and small commands.
It is imperative not only that the leader know the name and address of his
subordinates,
but also that he's familiar with their characteristic characteristics.
Cool.
No.
Your people literally know your people.
Interest yourself and living conditions of the members of your command,
including their family environment,
food,
clothing,
ability.
Make ample provision for and give personal invisible attention to the various
personal services,
particularly those concerned with the personal problems of individuals.
Provide for the spiritual welfare of your command by supporting religious
activities.
Protect the health of your command by active supervision of hygiene and
sanitation.
Support actively a safety program.
Determine the mental attitude of members of your command by frequent informal
visits and by using fully and fully all available sources of information
administered justice in partially to all without fear of favor.
When punishment is necessary,
the commander should be fair,
consistent and impersonal.
Punish in private,
private with dignity and with human understanding,
never awarded degrading punishment.
Avoid punishing a group for the faults of the individual.
Always make the individual feel that the punishment is temporary and that
improvement is expected and I think when he says expected or that when they say
expected,
I don't think they're talking about like,
Hey,
I expect you to do better.
It's more like,
hey man,
like I know you can do better because that's what they're talking about.
And it's an interesting one.
The avoid punishing a group for the fault of the individual because the military
is famous for doing that,
especially in like bootcamp scenarios where we're going to keep doing these
until we can all do them in unison,
whatever jumping jacks.
But beyond those scenarios,
that's a,
that's not always the best call to make.
Yeah,
because that's like,
it's one of those,
in football they'd do that to real like obvious.
Like I like you,
if you mess up everyone else does the bell from bear crawls and you stand and
watch a psychological punishment to the guy more than the team.
Yeah.
So it's like,
it's like a different approach,
but you know,
I get it for that very reason.
By the way I it,
it works in the bootcamp environment where the or the team training environment
where you're trying to create this overall cohesion by making everyone rely on
each other and be able to count on each other as if to say in a demonstrated
way,
like when you mess up,
this affects the team and put the peer pressure on everyone to step up their
game.
Right.
If we don't make this time,
if everyone doesn't make this time,
then we're all gonna get punished.
Okay.
So we don't want that on our backs.
But when you get into a business situation,
you start punishing people for the group failure.
That's,
that's not as effective in building in fact what they're going do.
Sometimes it starts ripping things apart.
They're going to be careful with that one.
Haiti.
Yeah.
Uh,
next.
Ensure fair and equitable distribution of privileges such as past as leads and
rotation and courage,
educational development by providing educational opportunities for members of
your command.
I often ask groups this,
leaders in companies,
I'll say,
who here had someone that truly took a vested interest in you and helped you
move up the ranks through the chain of command in your industry?
And everyone will raise their hand just about,
you know,
99% of people raise their hand and I'll say,
how good did that feel?
One to 10,
to have someone that was completely invested in helping you.
Uh,
who's,
who's a nine or above,
everyone raises their hand.
Imagine how good that feels when you do that.
For someone else because it's real easy to forget that someone helped you.
It's easy to forget
that you got hoisted up to your position of power by other people that were
willing to sacrifice their time and their energy to improve your lot in life.
So when you get the opportunity to improve someone else's lot in life,
do it.
Hmm.
Next techniques for keeping your men informed,
explained to your principal subordinates why any particular task must be
accomplished and how you propose to do it.
So importance of understanding why.
Assure yourself by frequent inspections and visits that subordinates are
transmitting necessary information to the men.
Okay,
so you just can't expect it.
You got an inspected.
Keep your principal subordinates informed of plans for future operations.
Subject only to security restrictions.
Disseminate information concerning the capabilities of our weapons compared to
those of an active or potential enemy,
where an enemy has an initial advantage.
Show how this can be overcome.
Be sure the troops are informed of the capabilities and limitations of
supporting units,
arms and services.
Be alert to detect the spread of false rumors.
Stop rumors by replacing them with
the truth.
Build confidence in a spree decor by exploiting all information concerning
success,
successes of the command.
That's,
that's a big one,
is a lot of times businesses,
companies,
people,
they do things.
Things go well and they don't tell anybody about it and it gets lost.
Whereas if you want to build morale and you want to get momentum,
you've got to tell everyone,
hey,
we're out here and we're crushing it.
Hmm.
Principle five how to set the example,
number one,
be at all times physically fit,
mentally alert,
well-groomed,
and correctly dressed.
There you go.
That's how you set the example to master your emotions.
The commander who is subject to intemperate bursts of anger or to periods of
depression will have difficulty in gaining and holding respect and loyalty of
his subordinates.
So true.
Hm.
Maintain an optimistic outlook.
The will to win is infectious.
The leader fosters it by capitalizing on his units,
capabilities and success is not on his limitations or failures.
Maintain an air of outward calmness.
The more difficult the situation,
the more important this becomes.
So when things start going sideways,
you gotta stay calm.
Conduct herself so that your personal habits are not open to censure course
behavior and vulgarity are the marks of an essentially and unstable character.
These together with a failure to be punctual and a tendency towards selfishness
and self indulgence in luxuries not available to the command in general are
inevitably resented by all ranks.
So that's what we were just talking about.
But yeah,
man,
you to hold yourself to a little higher standard,
maybe even a lot higher standard because they're watching you
cooperate in spirit as well as in fact,
this is what I just talked about and what we just talked about.
It's not just,
hey,
I'm pretending to do this cause it's gonna make things easier for me.
It's,
I truly am doing this cooperation must work in two directions.
It arises from a whole hearted desire by all members to further the effective
operations of the team
exercise initiative and promote this spirit of initiative in your subordinates.
Be conspicuously loyal to those below you as well as those above you support
those under you.
As long as the individuals concerned have been discharging their duties
competently.
The commander who seeks,
however,
to protect an incompetent subordinate from correction by a higher commander is
being disloyal himself.
Loyalty is a prime trait of leadership and demands unqualified support of the
policies of the superior officers.
Whether the individual concerned personally favors them or not.
That's the whole conversation we just had about loyalty.
Avoid the development of a click of favorites.
While it is difficult to avoid,
I liked this one cause they readily admit this is interesting,
so avoid the development of a click of favorites,
but then they kind of throw this on there.
While it is difficult to avoid being partial to subordinates who have rendered
loyal and superior service over a period of time,
that's a temptation to show partiality should be vigorously resisted.
So they're saying,
I guess this can be hard because you've got somebody on your team that's just
doing great things natural.
Yeah,
I always had a hard time with that.
makes sense.
I wouldn't be overt about it,
but if you were doing good,
you were going to get some,
some Benny's from,
yeah.
Be Morally courageous.
The commander who fails to stand by his principles where the welfare of his
command is concerned or who attempts to avoid responsibility for mistakes of his
command will fail to gain or hold respect of his associates or subordinates.
And the last one,
share danger and hardship.
A leader who has elements of his command subjected to danger or to hardship of
any kind,
should visit them as often as possible to demonstrate without Austin station
that his willingness to assume his share of the difficulties.
So those are some techniques for that principle six,
how do we ensure that the task is understood,
supervised and accomplished?
Here are some techniques for that through study and practice.
Develop the ability to think clearly,
to issue a clear,
concise,
positive order.
Isn't it strange that I ended up using the word simple,
clear,
concise,
and they use the word,
I guess it's not that weird,
but it's,
it's funny to see,
to encourage subordinates to seek immediate clarification about any point in
your orders or directors that they do not understand perfectly.
So that's something that so many people fail to do is everyone just keeps their
mouth shut.
No,
I don't have any questions.
It's so funny.
These,
and this one really is,
seems so obvious,
like,
oh yeah,
you're not clear.
Like,
oh,
what do you do if you're not clear?
It's this big mystery what to do.
Everyone knows.
Even if you're a kid,
you know,
like,
oh,
I didn't understand that.
Like what do you mean?
What do you mean?
Why?
Why he and the kids always ask why?
Why do I live?
Same thing.
So it seems super obvious,
but yeah,
when you're in there,
you want to keep your mouth shut.
There's all these different human,
yeah,
you don't want to look stupid.
You don't want to open,
you know,
you don't want to be that guy.
I
question your subordinates and assistance to determine if there's any doubt or
misunderstanding to the task.
So this is something that we always say.
How do you know people understand?
You ask them and you just don't ask them.
Do you understand?
You're asking me to explain it back to you.
Make every means available to your subordinates to assist them in accomplishing
their mission.
Principle seven train your men as a team.
Ensure by inspections and training tests that your command is being trained in
accordance with the training programs and doctrine prescribed by higher
authority.
Make sure the best available facilities for team training are provided.
Ensure that all trading is purposeful.
Ensure that each element of the command is acquainted with the capabilities and
limitations of all other elements,
thereby developing mutual trust and understanding.
Yeah,
ensure each subordinate leader understands the mechanics of tactical control for
his own echelon of command.
Predicate team training on modern realistic conditions.
Insist that each officer and enlisted man knows the functions of each other.
Officer and enlisted man with whom he habitually operates.
Insist that each of these no one understand each other,
their traits,
peculiarity,
strengths and weaknesses.
So often in companies,
this is not happening in businesses.
It happens pretty well in the military,
but in businesses you'll have departments.
They've no idea what another department does.
No idea how they do their job,
no idea what their job even entails.
Lafe and I used to make tea,
make teams brief what their department did and when we get them in there in the
room,
you'd see people would just had no idea what the other teams were doing.
They'd be like,
oh,
I didn't know you guys did that.
Hello,
you guys been doing that for nine years.
Demand the highest standard of discipline and teamwork in all training.
We support that.
Seize opportunities to train with other units,
both combat and service.
Principle eight make sound and timely decisions.
This first one here,
these are techniques again,
develop a logical and orderly thought by constant practice in making objective
estimates of the situation.
Making an estimate is not restricted to the military to employ.
It is employed in everyday life of all persons.
So how do you make decisions?
How do you do that?
What and then you come up with is kind of a process that you,
you flow through in your brain off to add that to the protocol book,
how to make decisions and so far as time and occasion permit plan for every
contingency that can reasonably be foreseen.
Consider the advice and suggestions of your subordinates before making your
decisions.
Of course announced decisions in time to allow subordinates to make necessary
plans.
Boom.
Principle nine is seek responsibility and develop a sense of responsibility
among risk subordinates.
So this one says,
learn the duties and responsibility of your immune immediate supervisor.
I actually think you learn your immediate supervisor and his boss.
You want to at least know what's going on.
Seek diversified assignments which will give you responsibility and command
experience.
People always want to stay and we'll do,
we'll keep doing what they're good at.
They don't want to venture out into the different world.
Take advantage of any opportunity which offers increased responsibility.
Do that.
Oh,
this is a task that needs to be done.
Someone needs running.
I got it.
I'm on it.
Perform every task larger,
small to the best of your ability.
And this goes back to whatever,
a few podcasts ago we were talking about how you do anything is how you do
everything.
And I gave some slack on that one,
but these guys got no slack at all.
Perform every task larger,
small to the best of your ability.
Your reward will consist of increased opportunity to demonstrate your fitness to
perform bigger and more important tasks.
What does that mean?
The better you do,
the more work you're going to get.
That's what it means.
Oh,
tell your subordinates what to do,
not how to do it.
Hold them responsible for the results.
Delegate and supervise,
but do not intervene except when urgently necessary.
Avoid usurping the prerogatives of your subordinates.
This is actually such a concise,
clear rule.
Tell your subordinates what to do,
not how to do it.
Hold them responsible for the results.
Delegate and supervise but do not intervene except when urgently necessary.
Avoid usurping the prerogatives of your subordinates.
That is really good advice for anyone in a leadership position.
If you could follow that advice right there,
your world is going to be so much better.
Provide all personnel with frequent opportunities to perform duties of the next
higher echelon.
Yes.
T bruiser we made all the junior officers be ground force commander before we
went overseas kind of experience and then they went overseas.
And did it be quick to recognize accomplishments of your subordinates when they
demonstrate initiative and resourcefulness.
Correct.
Errors in the use of judgment and initiative in such a way as to encourage the
individual.
Okay.
Avoid public criticism or condemnation.
Be Liberal.
However,
openly giving praise for which is which is deserved.
Give unstintingly help give unstintingly of help and advice when you are
requested by those under your command,
that one's pretty obvious.
Ensure that your personnel are assigned positions commensurate with demonstrated
or potential ability.
That's important.
Get someone that's got some potential,
put them in a good spot.
Okay.
Be Prompt and fair and backing subordinates to the limit
until convinced otherwise have faith in each subordinate.
Yeah,
I think you got to take a little time to make sure you build that up is don't
dive in with complete faith and give a little task first.
Demonstrate to your command that you are ready and willing to accept
responsibility.
Yes.
I want our ship
principle 10 techniques on how to employ
your command in accordance with its capabilities.
Number one,
no understand and apply the principles of war
and those principles of war of different than what we're talking about right
now.
The principles of war that they're talking about,
our objective offense,
mass,
economy of force,
maneuver,
unity of command,
security,
surprise and simplicity.
Those are the
okay
principles of war that they're talking about.
So you got to know those,
so that means in your company you got to understand the principles that you're
operating in.
Keep yourself informed as to the relative operational effectiveness of various
elements of your command.
Be sure the tasks assigned are reasonably possible of accomplishment.
Analyze any tasks assigned.
If it means you're disposable,
if means that your disposable appear inadequate of form,
inform your media commander and request additional means.
Yeah.
It's not like,
oh,
I'll get anything done,
boss.
I can do anything.
It's like,
no,
actually I'm going to need some more support over here and we need some more
people,
money,
resources,
whatever.
Make every effort to equalize tasks proportionally over appropriate periods of
time.
Among the several elements of your command.
No,
don't just ladened down one group.
If you've got one group that's so much stronger than the other group moves and
people around,
she gets him a equality there.
And here's the last principal techniques.
Take responsibility for your actions.
Principal 11
extreme ownership.
Remember that you are
responsible for all your command does or fails to do except justified criticism.
Adhere to what you think is right and have courage of your convictions.
So
those are some,
uh,
some heavy hitters.
What this book does now,
and I'm not going to do it,
is it actually breaks down how the,
what different leadership techniques you can use at every level.
So it talks about,
and you know what,
I haven't said this yet.
This book is free.
This is online.
You can Google 1951.
Leadership Fm 10,
tack 22.
Was it a,
uh,
like a pdf?
Yeah,
that's like a pdf.
And so you can,
you can look it up and you can figure out where you are.
It talks about technique useful to noncommissioned officers.
It talks about techniques for,
um,
regimental and lower unit commanders.
It talks about commanders of divisions and higher units and it goes through what
kind of techniques you can use in each one of these positions.
And they're all solid information,
solid information and points out good.
Not just what the rules are about the techniques that are used to,
to kind of make them happen
and so solid a bunch of information there that again,
you can easily give us.
This book is a pretty short read.
I've read a bunch of it right now.
I mean I actually kind of went crazy with my red with my red pen,
just circling everything and saying,
hey,
read this too.
But
there's a ton of it in here,
but I'm going to skip back to,
um,
there's skip that information and look it up.
Go read it.
It's powerful stuff.
And I'm gonna Kinda just jump ahead to this last little closing part that I
wanted to cover,
which is talking about how to train and it just talks about a few things.
Stress,
realism because we have to make training realistic.
That's what we have to do.
It's what I did when I was in the seal teams.
It's what you should do in whatever kind of organization you're in.
If you're an a,
if you're in a business,
you should send me that.
Make your training as close to real as you possibly can.
Another thing is require repeated drills in the execution of simple tactical
maneuvers.
What does that mean?
Repetition counts.
You have to repeat things over and over again if you want to get good at them.
Another important training tips,
stress the importance of each leader,
so placing himself and his headquarters that he can most readily coordinate all
efforts of his command and of the elements that may be supporting it.
Where you're located is important,
where you position yourself is important.
And so you've got to recognize that that's going to change depending on the
situation.
You've got to learn how to,
how to address that and how to pick the right spot to be in.
And the last one is last couple of stress.
The importance of exchange of information by all appropriate means.
So we got to communicate and the last one is have a well planned critique
immediately after each field exercise.
And that again wraps up this very,
very powerful summation.
Very simple,
very straightforward.
Um,
I feel like I actually could have talked about each one of these points
and going over examples that goes,
he's one of them is so important.
Yeah.
So I don't know,
maybe we'll do it again or they'll come up again.
But that's what you have.
And then just that closing point on having a well planned critique after every
field exercises,
what does that actually mean?
What that means is always be learning,
always be learning.
And
almost every one of these principles I recognized,
I have heard before,
I've definitely read them before.
We've covered them here before,
but I'm still trying to learn,
I'm trying to still trying to relearn even the same lessons after years of me
looking at this stuff,
which
I guess is me just kind of following the principles of themselves,
which is know your job,
know yourself and seek improvements.
That's what I'm trying to do.
And I think that's pretty much what anyone that's listening to this is trying to
do.
So,
I mean,
I guess Echo,
speaking of rule number two,
and speaking of us seeking to constantly improve ourselves,
what do you know about things that can help us improve our situation?
Support what we're trying to do in our self improvement journey.
Journey.
Sure.
Path,
path,
big time.
And actually you can support this podcast if they wish.
If you want to while you support your own journey down the path.
Yes.
Of discipline.
And keep in mind this path that we are on also brings along others.
Even if they're not like on the path with you,
your results of being on the path improve them as well.
I found that out directly.
How many capacities?
Okay,
so let's say,
you know that sounded like one of those statements that you make where you're
just wanting a prompt
so you can tell a long story.
Yes,
that's what it sounded like.
You were ready as he said.
How'd you find out a youth bubble?
You're not eating well.
So Ian,
Ian,
a family household in a group setting or whatever,
right?
Things can get stressful.
I'm not saying they're stressful every single day,
every moment,
but they can get stressful.
Right.
So,
you know,
like any,
you know about stressful situations,
I'm assuming a little bit.
Yeah.
So when everyone's panicking or whatever,
stressed out or whatever,
and you get one guy who jumps in there,
the situation,
not panicking,
not overtly,
uh,
stressed out and he,
he can sort of manage not only himself,
but his tiny environment.
It's contagious.
Other people will get that and they start doing that as well,
whether it be in the immediate situation or just in general.
We just covered this is part of the book,
right?
Yeah.
Big Time.
How that leads,
first of all,
the leader can come from any rank and then when they step in that leadership and
the way that they act will spread throughout his team.
Oh yeah.
So you're confirming.
Yes.
Big Time.
And that goes for like us big time,
but huge,
huge,
huge day.
And so it's the soul,
if you're getting in shape,
right?
The people around you will sort of notice if you're like happier,
doing things more,
make getting more done around you,
you know,
taking responsibility for things.
You're taking out the trash,
every other nightmare for whenever it fills up.
I don't know when I,
it depends on how big your trashes I guess,
but if you're taking it out when it's full,
you don't let it overflow anymore.
People notice that.
I'm just saying and slowly by slowly,
especially if you're happier,
you know,
if you're treating them better and all this stuff,
they'll start doing it too.
Same thing with extreme ownership.
You know how like,
um,
you know,
if you,
if you come at a problem like,
hey,
that was my fault it most of the time,
eventually,
if not immediately they'll say,
well,
you know what,
it's kind of my,
yeah,
same exact thing.
So that's why you should be on the path and stay on the path because you're not
just helping yourself.
You're helping everyone around you.
Sir,
you are one of those things that you're doing on top of taking out the trash
when it needs to be taken out.
His Jujitsu?
No,
here's that's a,
it's kind of you.
Just this one of these ones where people might not.
Right.
Especially if you're a husband,
you want to do Jujitsu now,
but wait,
we have a family of six or more whatever or less,
I don't know.
And you have responsibilities in there.
Now you want to add this quote unquote extra curricular activity to these tasks.
That's what you're telling them,
right?
That's the situation.
Right.
But like I said,
one,
you get the benefits of Jujitsu and you come home,
you slowly become a different person,
a better person,
a better person in household is a better situation.
So for everyone in the household,
everybody and the neighbors and the neighborhood,
your whole street,
the whole town,
the whole world.
It's better.
Yes sir.
It is.
And when you do Jujitsu,
you will need a geek and a rash guard.
At least one I think.
Yeah.
What are the best guys in the whole wide world?
They are origin,
geese,
geese by far.
And they are made in America 100% sometimes people actually not about the keys,
but people still ask me,
you know,
some people will be like,
they don't like they started training and they don't like it.
Don't like,
Oh did you do
it?
Some people realize immediately like they get submitted and they're like,
you know,
they'll pull,
they'll post up on Twitter and they'll say,
I did my first Jiu Jitsu class yesterday.
I got submitted and beat up and I got submitted by a 15 year old girl.
You know,
it's the best thing ever,
right.
Some people say that because I think we're are doing a good job of setting the
expectations of the fact that it's going to,
you're going to get humbled,
nay.
One,
you're going to get humbled.
I actually don't care who you are.
Yeah.
You're going to get humbled because even if you're a d one wrestler,
you're going to come in there and it's gonna be humbling cause you're not gonna
be able to quite do what you think you're going to be able to do.
I mean,
you'll kill it.
Yeah.
You'll be able to take someone down.
You'll be able to,
you'll be,
but you won't be able to make them tap.
You won't really know how to,
I mean if,
unless the person doesn't know anything,
but if you're going against a blue belt or a purple belt,
going to be hard for you.
Yeah.
So my first,
um,
it was like,
it wasn't,
it was technically,
I guess my first or second day in a class setting.
It wasn't with dean.
You know,
I tried like to other gyms before he joined the team and I went and they were
like,
yeah,
you know,
I literally one,
did you get to class that I learned,
I don't even remember what it was.
So they're like,
yeah,
hey role,
now it's time to roll.
So I'm going,
I'm going to insist that way smaller than me.
And he was like within,
he had like a month,
I think I'm wanting to experience you.
I'm way bigger than us.
And he was a thing for like your example,
he didn't talk me out,
but I literally couldn't do anything gas and I'm so tired,
I'm cute.
And I'm like two 25 like solid.
He doesn't care.
He's,
and he's won 50 here's a eats about one 50 yes,
but here's the thing,
he's like a month or two in is a complete white belt too.
But I'm like new guy,
but I'm weighing more athletic.
Literally I could pick this guy up over my head,
literally couldn't do nothing,
couldn't even pass his guard.
And I knew what a guard pass.
I knew like you have to pass this guy's there.
And he was telling and he told me afterwards,
he was like,
Hey,
like you're,
you're expanding too much energy,
all this stuff or whatever.
And I'm thinking in my head,
man,
I don't,
I don't know that.
I mean obviously cause I'm tired,
but it just goes to show how much you just don't know about when you go in,
even though you're,
you're big and strong or whatever.
So yes,
you will get home.
Yeah.
You expect that part of it.
And then instead of when you do get beat up,
when you get choked,
when you get arm lock,
instead of getting mad and thinking,
I'm never going to do this again,
think to yourself,
I'm going to do this a lot until I can get good enough that some unknown person
can really
impose their will on me as a human being.
I didn't like that feeling,
man.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
it just,
it goes to show like that.
It,
it matters what response you have to it.
That's like the what really matters.
So yeah,
we are,
we're all going to get beat up.
We're all going to get submitted multiple,
when I say multiple,
probably thousands by people who are smaller.
Who Do you figure you want to start?
You get submitted 10 times a day when you start oil.
Yeah.
So you're getting submitted 50 times a week if you're training five days a week.
Smaller than you.
Bigger than you.
Smaller,
whoever,
all different people.
So yeah.
So how are you going to respond?
Are you going to respond?
My thing,
I never want that experience ever again.
Ever again.
Or are you just wanting to be with,
I want that skill,
whatever this guy obviously has or the,
all these people obviously have got it from this place by the way.
I know that too.
Yup.
Am I going to choose to be,
no,
I don't want that skill somewhere else.
You don't have to go to like some other country.
Yeah,
and generally in America you can just go down.
You can Google maps and you can find nine Jujitsu schools.
Well,
maybe not me around in San Diego.
You can.
In southern California,
if you're in other parts of the country,
you can probably find to try to options where you are most likely.
Yeah.
Now you could be way out in the middle.
Nowhere.
Cool.
Get some maths,
get some friends,
get one of those online programs.
You start learning,
go to youtube.
Youtube is free.
Free.
Just start.
Listen to what they're saying and trying it on your buddies and you'll start to
learn Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Boom.
On the path to get your,
get an origin g a hundred percent made in America.
Good.
Jeez.
Here's the engineered for Jujitsu.
Great train was commenting on his new origin gate,
the new one.
He was like,
oh,
it's like a pearl.
It's like a thing and I,
and he doesn't like geek out over that kind of stuff typically.
But he was and for good reason and you know you kind of gloss over like made in
America.
That's actually a really big deal.
It's actually bringing back an industry that had left that had left this country
and bringing it back where we are.
We have hired the people that got left behind.
They're not left behind anymore.
They're up there.
They're making the best games in the world.
You know a small town in New England bringing back that economy.
Yeah.
So when you support origin,
you're actually supporting much more than Jujitsu.
You're supporting much more than this podcast.
You're actually supporting America and you're supporting the working people of
America.
That's what you're doing.
So we're going to try and continue to drive down this path to continue to grow
this company where we can bring a significant amount of jobs back to America,
employ more people,
and let other people grow and pay and provide for their families.
That's what the goal is.
And it feels great to go up to Farmington and be there in the factory and see
what is being made by this tradition of craftsmanship.
And you know,
right now we're,
we're bringing on the shoes,
the boots and same thing.
We got people that,
you know,
haven't been able to work in this industry for 12 years and since they shut down
the factories up there and outsourced the jobs and sent the machines overseas.
So that's what actually happened to actually happen.
And the people talk about the,
the,
the corporate greed,
right?
Hey,
it's going to cost me whatever it's going to cost me.
I can save a little bit of money by shipping these things overseas.
We'll let all these people go and that's fine.
I don't care.
Well,
we do care,
we do care.
And we recognize that the strength of America comes from our economy and the
strength of our economy comes from the ability of our,
of the working people in America to have a job and work hard and make the best
product in the world.
That's what we're doing.
Yeah man.
And overall to it,
Pete has that cool little series where it'll sort,
it'll show the little,
yeah.
Yeah.
So he's like,
yeah we have this problem.
So I'm,
I think I'm going to call this guy.
And this guy he's talking about is the old school expert who,
you know,
like it doesn't do it anymore for sure.
But he has all this call,
this knowledge,
he comes in,
boom,
boom.
Solving problems and then,
and it shows like the interaction between like the workers and Pete and
everybody,
right?
So it's not like this,
I mean no offense to China,
but it's not like your typical go to China and you turn and burn these days,
you know,
no defects or whatever.
Whatever that video series is called origin HD.
What's the name of the,
of the,
the youtube channel is,
I think its origin.
Bjj.
So if you go to that,
you can get behind the scenes on what's being made on,
who's making it on,
on the kind of effort that the team up in origin is putting in to make the
quality that's up there.
It's,
it's awesome to watch.
It's awesome to watch so that they got a bunch of clothes up there too.
Rash Guards,
um,
you know,
t shirts and all that you can get from origin.
We also,
yeah,
and,
and now we have genes which are going to be live like this week we have where
they're in production.
We hired a bunch of people,
a bunch of more people.
So don't just run out and buy a pair of jeans made in China by somebody in a
sweat shop,
buy a pair of jeans here that are made in America from the dirt until they're on
your legs.
All that made in America.
So yeah,
you can get that.
We also have a,
we also have supplements,
supplements that,
supplements that.
I basically wanted to make exactly how I wanted them.
That's basically what they are saying,
Hey,
this is what has always worked for me.
These things,
put them together,
combine them,
um,
and,
and make them,
and also,
by the way,
if it's something that I'm going to eat,
make it taste good and here's how we're going to do it,
we're going to sweeten it with monk fruit,
which is a fruit.
Obviously it's not a camp.
There's not some,
you know,
group of whatever scientist in a laboratory trying to create something that
tastes good through a bunch of cancer causing crap.
No,
I'm taking a fruit,
putting it in there.
That's why milk tastes so good.
Is there any better way to get additional needed protein?
No,
there is not a little better way.
Now my house where I live,
my family now,
it's who can make the best milkshake,
right?
I mean my wife comes in the other day,
she's holding the Gob and she's like,
she gets,
she lets me tasting.
I'm like,
what in God's name?
It's so good.
So good.
I don't even want to eat anything else.
It was coconut milk,
vanilla gorilla,
three ice cubes,
one chunk,
like a quarter of a banana.
The thing tasted like,
uh,
Gore made dessert.
Redonkulous if you [inaudible] this is a little added thing.
I put some,
uh,
like MCT oil or coconut frozen a little,
you'll hear,
you know,
like just a little bit,
not like too much or whatever.
And it's weird.
So it more adds to the texture than it does the taste.
But that's like a little sneaky way to make your tastes more quality than,
than the other competitors.
It's ridiculous that it could be good for you.
Yeah,
it is.
Cause you feel like you're just ate an ice cream shake.
Right.
But you didn't,
you got high quality protein,
you got probiotics.
Oh,
it's getting ridiculous.
Sneaky thing you do with your kids by the way.
You can use where you can walk to or whatever,
whichever.
By the way,
strawberry,
strawberry milk for adults is coming.
It should be out pretty soon.
And I've tried it.
It's,
it's absolutely,
completely and utterly ridiculous how good it tastes and that it can be good for
you.
Yeah,
it's totally ridiculous.
Did they send you a sample of it?
Of the,
of the strawberry adult milk?
Oh No,
no,
no.
I can't believe it.
Okay.
So anyways,
there you go.
So what you do with your kids is,
you know how you got to threaten them with punishment.
Every once in a while I'll say,
hey,
no dessert.
Or you want to use it as an incentive.
Like,
Hey,
if you can clean up your room within the next,
you know,
three minutes or whatever,
you can have a mall,
I'll give you a yes.
And don't even say multiple.
Just get hockey.
I'll make you a,
unless they already know,
unless they're in the know then it,
but you
said,
I'll give you a special dessert or treat or whatever.
You make it with the milk.
You put the little bit of Amse,
DOL,
you know,
you make it taste all gourmet the way you did.
So boom,
they clean up their room within three minutes.
By the way,
whenever time parameters,
you get home,
they get the Malke all thinking they won,
they won the game.
You know,
I did that little task that you told me that and I,
and I saved the deal.
Right.
God,
my dessert.
You want to,
to the whole team one team,
one whole team.
I like it.
Uh,
don't forget about joint warfarin.
Krill oil.
Recently Leif Babin forgot about joint warfare and he got off the mat and he,
he texted me,
he's like,
Bro,
I didn't take joint warfare for like three days for whatever.
He's traveling or wants something.
And he's like,
I got done rolling.
And I was like,
man,
why am I so jacked up?
Oh yeah.
Because I haven't taken any joint warfare.
Got Back on the joint warfare back on the good to go train.
Yeah.
Which was ironic and I addressed this on that.
Uh,
there was a post that he made his out,
the one that they,
yeah,
so I'm meeting,
we posted it cause he was like,
I can't even believe this.
It's ridiculous the difference that you notice yet.
And like I said,
the irony there is early on it wasn't with joint where it feels with Krill oil.
I forgot mine in New York.
Oh yeah,
in New York.
And Jenna comes in,
you know,
actually I told [inaudible],
I told her a bunch of people,
but you know,
no one really wanting to give me any
because I traveled with like the number of that I need for that time period that
army gone for.
I can't spare any.
It's really neutral.
Running around with like extra krill oil.
Should you
change,
you're not going to be by water in the field.
I carried it.
I'm drinking it unless you're going to die.
Maybe I'll say really?
Yeah,
exactly.
In high school when I went,
me and jade would,
when my brother,
me and my brother would lift.
So we were real like discipline with the post workout meal.
Right.
And it wouldn't,
I wouldn't say it would be measured out,
but there'd be enough,
you know,
you'd have to have a specific amount for the postworkout meal.
So if we were to go buy Sushi or go buy something like good and they'd be,
you know,
my brother,
I would ask,
oh,
let me get something,
let me taste it.
We'd say,
I can't spare the nutrients so I can't give you any I want to share,
but I can't square the nutrients from my,
from my workout,
whatever.
So that's no,
that's what you did.
That's what you do with your CHRO.
None the less that,
uh,
after a few hours of,
of failure,
you know,
getting more krill oil general Leif Babin came through with the Krill oil.
Nice.
Yeah.
So it's kind of newer back in the game.
Oh,
huge time.
So it was just ironic that leaf,
Jenna's husband went through the same deal.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful with that.
You don't want to run down,
fall off.
And you do,
you mentioned where your kid mark,
if you've got kids getting more of your kid milk,
don't even play around,
don't even play around.
What are you gonna give them
a Hershey's syrup to make chocolate milk?
You'd give them Nestle's Quik to make chocolate milk.
Why don't you just give them a big glass of type two diabetes?
Because that's what you're doing.
Or you can say,
hey,
here's something that tastes better and is incredibly good for you.
Yes.
So there you go.
Where your kid mark,
you can get some of that.
Also you want to represent while on the path jock was a store.
It's called Jocko store,
obviously original.
Yeah,
we all know that.
I think by now,
well actually maybe not everybody on the less Jocko store.com that's where you
can get your discipline equals freedom tee shirts,
rash guards knew and out.
By the way,
if a new rash guard out stand by to get some stand by to get some Jujitsu or
well where it is you're doing wait,
stand by to get the new rash guard or that's what the grass card says.
Well
good.
All right,
cool.
T shirts,
rash guards,
hats,
truckers had CBDS,
lightweight hoodies.
For those of you that live in the lower 48 states.
Nope.
Brady Lanter texted me.
He was like [inaudible] he's in Michigan,
he's in Michigan.
He said today is lightweight Hoodie Day.
So yeah.
Well he also did a good job of posting that little thing of him out in the
freezing cold and he was like,
we just need a lightweight up here cause he's hard to go.
Oh,
okay,
here's our car.
Well,
right.
Hey,
if you're not as hardcore as Brady in those circumstances,
we have heavy weighted,
he's two.
So boom,
light and heavy,
whatever you need,
whatever you like.
A lot of cool stuff on there.
If he likes something good.
So don't forget about Jocko white tea,
which I am currently drinking.
And the reason I'm drinking it as nominally cause it tastes good,
but also because I like having an 8,000 pound dead lift factually 100%
guaranteed.
If you don't,
if you,
if you drink a Jocko white tea and you can't dead lift a thousand pounds,
you can send me the empty can and I'll send you the nickel for the can.
Yeah.
So that's,
don't forget to subscribe to the podcast because if you don't,
then you just don't have to know what you're thinking.
World subscribe.
Yeah.
If you don't subscribe,
then you're not subscribed,
which isn't good because it gets,
when we launch it,
occasionally rare occasion,
we launched something randomly for like some kind of an event,
some kind of a situation for launch the rent.
So if you're just expecting,
oh,
it's Wednesday,
I know what I'm going to get,
get the podcast,
then you'd jump on there.
There was another one waiting for you.
Yeah.
So if you want to get those,
no,
those subscribe to the podcast wherever you subscribed to a podcast and don't
forget about the warrior kid podcast,
which is awesome.
For some reason,
I always clear myself hot to say that warrior kid stuff is awesome.
I think it's because I'm saying it as like a dad.
You know what I mean?
I'm not saying it directed at myself.
Yeah.
Look,
I don't mean like,
Hey,
I'm great at the warrior kid podcast.
I'm,
I'm lost.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying it as a dad.
If you can get your kid to listen to warrior could podcast,
it will benefit them greatly and trying to figure out the ways of the world.
Yeah.
And how to live in this crazy world that we have.
And also there's a warrior kid that makes soap in central California.
Well,
I guess it's southern California,
but anyways,
Irish oaks,
ranch.com young aid and running a business that he's 13 years old.
Pretty soon he's not going to be a kid anymore,
but in the meantime,
get some of his soap so you can stay clean.
And we got a youtube video channel,
is that what it's called?
Yeah,
yeah.
Two video channel.
Yeah,
right.
As opposed to youtube what?
Jay Audio Channel.
Audio channel.
Well anyways,
on that video channel on Youtube,
which the video channel is called Jocko podcast.
That's the video channel,
right?
So if you go to that,
you can watch a bunch of videos that Echo Charles made and you can watch this
podcast.
You can see what Echo Charles looks like.
He looks like,
not like what he sounds epidemic evidently.
And also he makes he,
he's he,
what do you,
what do you experiment with?
Yeah,
he makes videos with his own personal skills.
Right?
You have such an eloquent,
interesting thing is I feel like a lot of times when you make videos,
you're not,
you're experimenting in a way you're not,
it's not like,
it's not like I'm saying,
hey,
make this video and here's the effect that we want.
You're just over there just making videos and they just with your own vision.
Yeah.
Well the goal.
Okay,
so the goal,
well the goal for the whole youtube thing is sure.
The video version.
You want to watch the podcast,
which do,
you know men that's,
I dig it now.
A lot of people do that.
I did get,
um,
and then the excerpts,
we have excerpts on there too.
If you don't,
you know,
you can watch it.
You can share those.
Yeah.
Cool.
But yeah,
and then sure,
I'll take an excerpt.
Essentially take an excerpt and kind of video wise,
have some fun with it,
you know,
add some facts and music and stuff and yet it's very much experimental.
But what we should make a video of what my life would be like if everything was
reflective of how your videos are everywhere.
When things were exploding.
Thought about that.
Yeah,
that kind of funny actually that that warpath media that's essentially kindness
into the thing.
It's like if you're on the warpath and here's all the things that you're doing,
so it showed like you know the little videos like video clips of me when I,
or not of me that I got a view just doing their stuff.
Do you get to and writing and stuff so it probably,
if you're on the warpath that's kind of what it represents
a little bit.
Assume scenes.
Yeah,
just a path of destruction in a constructive way check,
so you can do that.
You can also get psychological warfare,
which is a little bunch of tracks to help you overcome moments of weakness,
which apparently are quite effective because I've had many people explained to
me that they utilize them regularly,
so psychological warfare,
iTunes,
Google play,
MP3 platforms of all kinds.
You can,
you can check that out.
Also check out flipside canvas,
which is Dakota Meyer.
If you haven't listened to episode one 15 of this podcast,
it's one of the most popular podcasts,
one of the heaviest podcasts.
What of most impactful podcasts and there's a lot of impactful podcasts and I
guess that's saying a lot,
but uh,
Dakota's making,
what are they,
what was he making?
One of those things called canvas.
Canvas is Bart art hanging in pieces and they,
he's got a bunch of different ones but he actually has made some kind of based
on this podcast,
he's got one that says discipline equals freedom and he's got one that says
good.
He's got one that says time is running out and he's got one that says get after
it.
So if you want to get one of those,
if you want to post that thing up then you can post it up.
You can just have a giant get after it on your ceiling where you sleep when you
wake up in the morning,
the first thing you see is a giant sign that says get after it.
So check out that.
Yes,
very good ones too.
I was looking at was actually browsing like a bunch of them.
Those are good men and made in America.
I forgot to say that,
but once again,
same thing.
Same thing as origin,
but now we're in Texas.
We're building,
we have the factory where making them,
we're printing them.
It's all American made,
so you're not just supporting Dakota who is an awesome guy to support.
You're also supporting just America in general,
which is a positive thing.
Also expanding our,
our home gyms.
This is what we're going to do.
We're going to go to audit.com/ [inaudible] and get your stuff there.
That's where you get good stuff.
Rings,
Kettlebells,
big deal.
That's like a staple.
The rings in the kettlebells.
Big staple in
a lot of good stuff on there.
Some those elk bars.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Those are a big deal to those will come in the,
in the clutch.
When you want a little snack,
you need a little something.
Get yourself one of those elk bars especially,
and if you're,
if you're lifting kettle bells,
you probably going to need some elk bars to supplement the scenario.
Oh yeah.
Big Time.
A lot of good stuff on there.
Like the,
like the
characters or whatever.
Right.
What did the kettle bells,
yeah,
boy.
Yeah,
the whole set.
Did you get,
did you get any star wars ones?
Yes.
Yeah,
the Star Wars.
Do you,
do you feel pride when you say that answers Oquist yes.
Yes.
As if like that makes you better than me.
A little bit.
Yeah.
Yes,
they do little bit,
but the,
yeah,
we'll what our wars doesn't really hit me like strong.
Yeah.
All right.
No it's good.
But it doesn't,
I don't know.
Well they have the Mar.
What about marvel?
Cause they have like a um,
uh,
iron man one to her
doesn't really.
Yeah,
that doesn't surprise me.
But it's dope though.
Yeah,
no,
I saw which one did you get?
Did you get Darth Vader know?
You've talked about the storm trooper?
Yeah.
I'm going to get the Darth Vader one for sure.
Let me get all that much.
Does,
how much does Darth Vader way,
um,
is that the biggest regret that,
because what's the biggest,
like a 48?
No,
it's bigger.
It's bigger than a 48 kilogram.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Oh,
sorry.
Sorry.
I was going to say that's the biggest I have.
It might be the seventh step up.
This arms race,
war
40 kilograms,
so all it's over a hundred pounds,
six pounds.
What's your biggest?
My biggest one is the big foot one.
90 90 pounds or something like that.
Okay,
that's cool.
Whatever.
But last anyway on.com a lot of good stuff on there.
Get something.
Hey,
I've got a bunch of books to Mike and the dragons book for younger kids where
they learn to deal with and overcome fear.
Weigh the warrior kid and Mark's mission and now we have booked three coming out
and actually a little kid posted a book review of way the warrior kid and we
have to repost it,
but it's legit,
you know,
little kids,
a BMX racer,
he talks about all the rules of the way the warrior kit and how they apply to
his life.
How he has to take care of his BMX bike,
take care of your gear,
has to eat properly,
has to get up early,
get on the plan.
So pretty cool to see if you want your kids to be on the plan or if you want
your neighbor kids to be on the plan or if you want your kids at the school get
this book series of books where the work at Mark's mission and book three coming
out.
It'd be on the LBR available for preorder very soon.
I'll let everyone know.
It's called a where there's a will and then the discipline equals freedom field
manual.
Just how to get after it mentally and physically.
Okay.
And emotionally.
Sure.
Feelings with it.
The fact that that book is continuing,
it's continuing to get the best feedback on that book.
Yeah,
so it was cool.
Now people are posting no pictures of it.
Yeah.
Okay.
This page got me through today,
so there you go.
Just one goes freedom field manual.
Get that one.
It's not on audible.
It's on iTunes.
Amazon music,
Google play on MP3 platforms.
Don't forget about extreme ownership.
The first book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin
about what we learned in combat and he how you can apply it to your business and
your world and your life.
And then we followed that up with the dichotomy of leadership at which we are
now getting multiple reports from the battlefield.
That the dichotomy of leadership,
it's is a little bit better.
People think,
Eh,
I am,
I am.
I kind of felt that way.
But you know,
extreme ownership has the core like it's always going to have,
it's always going to be the bigger brother.
But you never know man dichotomy sometimes that that other kid,
right?
Yeah,
that was,
the other kid has the,
has a little bit,
he can learn lessons.
That's exactly what happened with dichotomy.
We learned lessons after we wrote extreme ownership and said,
you know what the most,
you know what the hardest thing for people to do is balanced the dichotomy of
leadership.
That was chapter 12 in extreme ownership.
Then it became a whole book.
So it was kind of like Rambo.
Right.
You know?
So Rambo,
when people say,
who do you,
what do you think your ramble,
they're talking about Rambo first blood part too,
right?
Dichotomy is kind of like Rambo where like people are like,
oh,
I love the dichotomy it up.
But,
but the people who know know that first blood is the real movies.
The real oh g one that ramble is not better.
Ramble.
Ramble gets a lot of glory.
They get the praise and it's awesome.
Well,
one thing that I guarantee you is the dichotomy of leadership is not jaws to
yes.
Which no one talks about jaws to Dolan cares about Johnston was one is epic
thick.
Yeah.
So the dichotomy of leadership is it is epic in its own right and it can stand
on its own.
Yes.
But it's still going to be,
it's still on the shadow.
It seems to be coming out from the shadow.
I guess that's what I'm saying.
Just like Rambo.
Okay,
well that's good.
Don't forget about echelon front.
That is our leadership consultancy is we solve problems through leadership.
So it's me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flint Cochran,
Mike's Really Mike [inaudible].
And Jason Gardner,
go to Ashkelon,
front.com for details if you want us to come and help you align the leadership
inside your organization so you can destroy your competitors.
Is that a little bit much?
Maybe,
but what do you want to do?
Give them a gentle massage.
No,
you want to crush them.
So if you want to do that,
reach out echelon front.com don't forget about the muster.
We have musters.
It's a leadership event.
It's two days long.
We're doing it in Chicago,
in Denver and in Sydney this year.
Go to extreme ownership.com every one of these events that we've done a sold
out.
So these are all going to sell out.
They're on track to sell out right now.
So if you want to come to those,
go national in front.com and or extreme ownership.com and you can register now
before it sells out.
And when it sells out,
you're gonna be mad.
Don't be mad at me.
Take ownership of it.
I'm trying to take ownership right now,
telling you that it's gonna sell out.
I'm taking ownership of the fact that it's going to sell out and I'm trying to
communicate it to you.
Hopefully you listen.
So that's that ETF online.
If you can't make it to the monster or let's say you got 300 people in your
company or 3000 people in your company and you want to bring him all the muster
and you,
you can't or you want to bring echelon front end,
but echelon front,
we can't travel to the nine countries that your company is located in.
So guess what?
That's why we made,
yeah,
for mine.
So that you can do and your entire organization can get completely aligned in
how you are utilizing leadership across your organization.
So it's online,
but it's not just watching videos,
it's,
yes,
there's videos,
but it's also interactive where you,
where you get put into leadership scenarios and then you have to figure out what
to do.
And if you choose the wrong scenario,
you're going to lead your company or your platoon into a bad situation.
So check it out.
F online.com and I already talked about this,
he f Overwatch.
This is the company that we have now where we are taking special operations and
combat aviation people leaders and putting them into companies so that the
companies can utilize the leadership skills of these experienced combat leaders
to help their company lead to victory.
And as I mentioned earlier,
you don't,
you'd,
I recommend you don't hire just based on experience,
recommend you,
you hire people based on the talent that they have on especially the leadership
capability that they have and if you want to stay in the game with us.
Okay.
Echo and I are actually on the interwebs.
We are on Twitter,
we are on Instagram and we are on dot fight shoo pork.
Okay.
Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at jockowillink and thanks to the police and law enforcement
and firefighters,
paramedics,
EMT is correctional officer's border patrols,
all first responders,
including the dispatchers.
I spent some time,
as I said,
with the police out in North Carolina recently.
And uh,
what a tough job and what a great bunch of people out there putting it all on
the line to protect us here at home.
And of course to our military men and women,
like the one that I opened up this podcast with Fred Garland,
Bragg junior first lieutenant U s army killed in action in Vietnam on July 12th,
okay.
But a hero.
Okay.
A leader and an example to all
of us that regardless of the odds you are facing,
you can stand up and you can fight.
Okay.
And to everyone else out there,
you can do the same thing every day.
Stand up to whatever challenges you face and get after it
going.
Until next time.
This is echo and Jocko out.